du jour appelle la déclaration du
gouvernement sur la politique
énergétique de la France suivi d'un
débat en application de l'article
50-1 de notre Constitution
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
la transition énergétique est un sujet
clé
elle se trouve au croisement d'enjeux
fondamentaux pour notre pays et pour nos
compatriotes
je pense à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique à notre pouvoir
d'achat à notre souveraineté ou encore à
la compétitivité de nos entreprises
nous sommes bien conscients du défi
énergétique depuis longtemps
c'est pourquoi le président de la
République dès 2018 a chargé RTE
d'étudier les différents scénarios pour
mener notre transition énergétique
en février dernier à Belfort il a
présenté une stratégie avec comme cap la
sortie des énergies fossiles et la
neutralité carbone en 2050
quelques jours plus tard la Russie a
attaqué l'Ukraine et a changé l'ordre du
monde
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de
débattre de cette guerre et de ses
conséquences pour notre pays
il est clair que Vladimir Poutine est
prêt à toutes les violations du droit
international toutes les exactions et
tous les signes
Moscou a notamment décidé de faire de
l'énergie un objet de chantage
la raie quasi totale des livraisons de
gaz russes vers l'Europe créent des
risques de pénurie et accentue
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie
initiés depuis la reprise post-covide
à cette situation d'autres tensions
conjoncturelles s'ajoutent c'est le cas
sur le pétrole du fait également de la
guerre en Ukraine et du refus des pays
de l'OPE d'augmenter leur production
c'est le cas aussi pour l'électricité
avec un arrêt pour maintenance d'une
partie de notre parc nucléaire j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
enfin des changements structurels sont à
l'oeuvre je pense en particulier au
dérèglement climatique dont il faut
anticiper les effets sur notre
production d'électricité
il faut donc accélérer notre transition
écologique sortir au plus vite des
énergies fossiles
conquérir une plus grande indépendance
énergétique et décarbonée nos modes de
vie et notre économie
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer c'est
ensemble que nous réussirons
mesdames et messieurs les députés face à
cette situation critique nous tenons
notre cap protéger des Français
notre premier défi est de faire en sorte
que nous puissions traverser l'hiver
sans difficulté
désavant l’été nous avons pris des
mesures pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements en gaz nous avons
décidé de porter nos stocks de gaz à
100% un objectif qui est désormais
atteint nous avons diversifié nos
approvisionnements en nous tournant
notamment vers la Norvège l'Algérie et
les États-Unis
nous avons augmenté les capacités de nos
terminaux métaniers et avec le Parlement
nous avons levé les verrous pour
installer rapidement un nouveau terminal
métallier au Havre les travaux sont en
cours
ces décisions nous protègent elles vont
également nous permettre de faire vivre
la solidarité européenne
quand quelques-uns on l'a vu courte et
veulent par pure dogmatisme tournait le
dos à l'Europe ils oublient que le gaz
que nous exportons désormais à nos
voisins nous permet en retour de
recevoir l'électricité dont nous avons
besoin
ne pas jouer la solidarité ce serait
risqué de manquer d'électricité
une fois de plus les prétendues
solutions des nationalistes se
retourneraient contre les Français
en même temps que nous agissons pour
disposer du gaz nécessaire nous mettons
tout en oeuvre pour rétablir notre
production d'électricité
notre parc nucléaire est dans une
situation d'indisponibilité
exceptionnelle mais conjoncturelle
cela s'explique d'une part par le
rattrapage des maintenances qui n'avait
pas pu se faire durant la période covid
et d'autre part par un problème dit de
corrosion sous contrainte détectée il y
a un an et qui a causé l'arrêt de 12
réacteurs pour contrôler et réparation
de premier réacteur on redémarré et le
calendrier prévoit une accélération des
remises en service en novembre et en
décembre je sais les équipes d'EDF
extrêmement mobilisées
nous devons néanmoins nous préparer à
tous les cas de figure
pour cela nous avons mis en place le
dispositif Ecowatt véritable météo de
l'électricité qui indiquera les
éventuelles tensions sur le réseau en
cas de tension extrême un signal
éco-ouat rouge sera émis et nous
appellerons les entreprises les
collectivités et nos compatriotes à
baissé leur consommation
nous préparons aussi à l'éventualité de
devoir procéder à des coupures ciblées
et de très courte durée
parce que nous avons anticipé la
situation parce que nous faisons preuve
de solidarité européenne parce que nous
pratiquons les sobriété j'y reviendrai
nous pourrons limiter au maximum
l'impact de la situation énergétique sur
notre pays cet hiver
dans le même temps nous devions répondre
à une autre urgence protégez les
Français les entreprises et les
collectivités face à l'explosion des
factures de gaz et d'électricité en
Allemagne en Italie en Belgique au
Royaume-Uni les montants payés par les
consommateurs ont explosé et les prix
ont parfois été multipliés par plus de
deux de notre côté nous avons mis en
place les mesures les plus protectrices
d'Europe ainsi dès octobre 2021 un
bouclier tarifaire a bloquer les prix du
gaz et limiter la hausse des prix de
l'électricité nous avons décidé de
prolonger ce bouclier tarifaire sans
action de notre part les factures
auraient doublées grâce à cette mesure
la hausse du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité a été limitée à 15% pour
les ménages les très petites entreprises
et les plus petites collectivités
par ailleurs ce bouclier est complété
par des soutiens spécifiques pour nos
compatriotes qui se chauffent au bois ou
au fioul
évidemment notre action ne se limite pas
au ménage et nous avons pris des mesures
fortes pour nous entreprises et nos
collectivités
nous déployons 2,5 milliards d'euros
pour aider les collectivités à faire
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
grâce à deux dispositifs l'amortisseur
électricité et le filet de sécurité
quant aux entreprises des aides ciblées
sont déjà mises en place notamment pour
les plus consommatrices de plus les TPE
qui ne sont pas protégés par le bouclier
tarifaire ainsi que les PME
bénéficieront également de l'amortisseur
électricité
au total l'ensemble de ces mesures
représente un effort de près de 12
milliards d'euros en faveur des
entreprises et des collectivités un
effort qui sera notamment financé par la
récupération des marges exceptionnelles
des énergéticiens à hauteur de 7
milliards d'euros
cette taxation exceptionnelle des marges
des énergéticiens et donc intégralement
redistribué aux collectivités et aux
entreprises c'est une mesure juste et
efficace une nouvelle fois nous avons
préféré l'action utile plutôt que les
effets d'annonce
mais au-delà des mesures d'urgence nous
sommes au front pour faire baisser
durablement les prix de l'énergie
soyons d'abord lucides les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité ne reviendront pas
au niveau artificiellement bas de la
période covid
mais les niveaux actuels sont très
excessifs par rapport au coût de
production et tiré vers le haut par la
spéculation et des craintes exagérées de
pénurie
nous voulons donc ramener les prix à des
niveaux raisonnables et cohérents par
rapport au coût de production
c'est un travail que nous menons en
européen le président de la République
est pleinement mobilisé sur le sujet
cela nous a permis d'obtenir une
véritable feuille de route lors du
Conseil européen des 20 et 21 octobre
dernier tout d'abord nous allons mener
un dialogue renforcé avec les
partenaires fiables qui nous fournissent
du gaz en exploitant le poids commercial
de l'Union européenne ensuite nous
sommes d'accord pour mettre en place des
achats groupés qui nous permettent
d'éviter la concurrence entre État
membre la Commission a formulé une
proposition en octobre pour fixer les
règles qui permettront aux États et aux
entreprises d'agir de concerts dans le
dialogue avec nos fournisseurs
ce dispositif est en cours de discussion
et sera soumis à l'approbation du
Conseil des ministres de l'énergie du 24
novembre enfin nous avançons vers l'idée
d'un plafonnement temporaire des prix du
gaz la Commission a pris l'engagement de
présenter les concours d'une proposition
à la matière dans les prochains jours
parmi les options mentionnées par le
Conseil européen d'octobre figure
notamment l'idée de plafonner le prix du
gaz utilisé dans la production de
l'électricité à l'échelle européenne
ce dispositif a permis de diviser par 3
le prix de l'électricité en Espagne
plus largement enfin cette crise nous
invite à réformer rapidement et en
profondeur le marché européen de
l'électricité la feuille de route
européenne ne prévoit désormais
expressément le Conseil européen a ainsi
demandé à la Commission d'accélérer les
travaux à ce sujet nous devons trouver
des solutions durables pour offrir aux
Européens des prix raisonnables et
proche des coûts de production
ne soyons pas naïfs les années à venir
seront difficiles notamment en matière
d'approvisionnement en gaz toutes ces
mesures sont donc essentielles pour
permettre à notre pays et à l'Europe
d'affronter la situation énergétique
dans la durée
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
répondons à l'urgence avec force et
détermination mais nous devons dans le
même temps nous préparer et investir
pour notre avenir
les énergies fossiles ont des effets
dont nous connaissons les ravages sur la
planète elle nous expose à des
fluctuations de prix majeurs elles sont
une source de fragilité dans notre quête
de souveraineté nationale et européenne
mais comme nous en sommes dépendants
pour notre quotidien nous continuons à
les consommer nous devons en sortir nous
voulons être la première grande nation
industrielle à s'émanciper des énergies
fossiles c'est le cap fixé par le
président de la République début février
à Belfort avant même le début de la
guerre en Ukraine
je crois que nous n'atteindrons la
neutralité carbone ni par la peur ni par
la pensée magique des changements
radicaux nous attendent nous avons
besoin d'une stratégie claire avec des
leviers déjà longs et des moyens c'est
précisément le but de la planification
écologique avec France nation verte et
c'est de cette manière que nous allons
réussir la transition énergétique
notre plan pour sortir des énergies
fossiles reposent sur trois piliers la
sobriété énergétique d'abord car la
meilleure énergie c'est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas une production d'énergie
d'électricité décarbonée ensuite autour
du nucléaire et du renouvelable et enfin
le développement de nouveaux vecteurs
énergétiques comme l'hydrogène
décarbonée
s'agissant du premier pilier dès le
discours de Belfort le président de la
République a évoqué la sobriété et en
juillet dernier il a lancé un appel à
nous en emparer
certains par idéologie ou par simpliste
veulent nous conduire vers la
décroissance
ce n'est pas la solution cela menacerait
notre modèle social et provoquerait un
rejet de notre transition énergétique la
sobriété ça n'est pas la décroissance de
notre économie la sobriété c'est baisser
un peu la température
décaler ses usages et éviter les
consommations inutiles c'est faire le
choix de la responsabilité pas de
l'infantilisation
ce sont aussi des actions structurelles
pour faire baisser nos consommations
c'est notre action en faveur des
mobilités propres c'est notre engagement
pour la rénovation massive des bâtiments
avec des investissements majeurs et
soutenables pour le secteur
la sobriété c'est efficace c'est une
source d'économie cela peut même être
une source de compétitivité
aujourd'hui état collectivité entreprise
particulier chacun doit prendre sa part
à la hauteur de ses moyens car je
l'affirme une nouvelle fois ça n'est
évidemment pas aux Français en situation
de précarité de faire de nouveaux
efforts
sous l'égide de la ministre de la
transition énergétique des travaux ont
été menés secteur par secteur pour
identifier les économies d'énergie
possible sans impact sur l'économie
chacun a pris la mesure de la situation
et nous avons été en mesure de présenter
au début du mois d'octobre un plan de
sobriété complet et ambitieux un plan
qui permettra de réduire notre
consommation énergétique de 10% en deux
ans et cela produit des résultats à date
nous avons consommé 15% d'électricité et
de gaz de moins qu'en temps normal
cependant nous devons collectivement
avoir conscience que la sobriété n'est
pas une mode le temps d'un hiver c'est
une nouvelle manière de penser et de
faire nous voulons baisser notre
consommation énergétique de 40 % d'ici
2050 ce plan de sobriété est donc un
point de départ
économiser massivement l'énergie est un
objectif majeur pour les années à venir
le deuxième axe de notre stratégie c'est
de nous appuyer sur un mix énergétique
décarboné et diversifier autour du
nucléaire et des énergies renouvelables
le rapport de RTE a été éclairant même
si nous consommerons moins d'énergie au
total la sortie des énergies fossiles
imposera de produire plus d'électricité
notamment pour satisfaire certains
nouveaux usages comme la mobilité
électrique ou des chauffages plus
performants
concrètement nous devrons être en mesure
en 2050 de produire jusqu'à 60%
d'électricité de plus qu'aujourd'hui
face à ce défi beaucoup ne jurent que
par les solutions toutes faites certains
ne parlent que de nucléaire et oublient
les risques de ne dépendre que d'une
source d'énergie tout en passant sous
silence ce qu'ils ont dit ou fait par le
passé
d'autres au contraire voudraient un mix
100% renouvelable je ne crois pas qu'il
soit réaliste ni en termes de capacité
ni en termes de gestion de
l'intermittence
[Applaudissements]
pour notre part nous croyons à
l'efficacité pas aux dogmatisme et au
contraire des prêches des idéologues la
crise actuelle nous montre l'urgence de
la diversification
nous ne pouvons pas nous appuyer sur une
seule ressource et nous devons réaliser
que dans les moments de tension il n'y a
pas de petits apports énergétique un mix
diversifié est un atout et une
protection c'est pour cela que nous
devons avancer sur deux jambes
renouvelables et nucléaire
alors oui nous allons développer
massivement les énergies renouvelables
c'est un choix pragmatique car c'est la
seule manière de répondre à nos besoins
immédiats quand il faut 15 ans pour
mettre en service un réacteur nucléaire
c'est un choix écologique car décarboné
c'est un choix économiquement rationnel
car les coûts des technologies
renouvelables ont beaucoup baissé et que
la production d'électricité renouvelable
permet désormais de dégager des recettes
pour l'État alors que les moyens de
production renouvelables coûtaient 6
milliards de subventions en 2021 il
rapporteront 10 milliards d'euros en
2022 qui seront intégralement
redistribués aux consommateurs
d'électricité
c'est un choix de souveraineté aussi
parce que nous allons continuer à
investir dans des filières industrielles
nos parc éoliens en mer comme celui de
Saint-Nazaire ont permis de construire
en France une véritable filière le
président de la République a fixé comme
objectif de construire 50 parcs éolien
en mer d'ici à 2050
il en est de même pour le solaire je
souhaite que nous puissions réinvestir
pour installer en France et en Europe la
production et l'assemblage des panneaux
et développer une nouvelle génération de
panneaux solaires nous voulons
multiplier par 10 la production
d'énergie solaire dans notre pays d'ici
2050 nous avons un objectif en vue
doublé nos capacités de production
d'électricité renouvelable d'ici à 2030
nous avons donc décidé d'accélérer le
rythme vous commencerez d'ici quelques
jours l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'accélération du développement des
énergies renouvelables
au Sénat chacun a débattu de ce texte en
bonne intelligence et a apporté sa
pierre pour l'améliorer le résultat a
été au rendez-vous puisque les groupes
socialistes écologiques la majorité
présidentielle les centristes et les
républicains ont voté ce projet de loi
je suis convaincu que cette méthode et
cet esprit de compromis pourront
également prévaloir à l'Assemblée
nationale
ce texte nous pouvons encore l'améliorer
ensemble nous y parviendrons par le
dialogue et la recherche de solutions
communes vous pouvez compter sur moi et
sur mon gouvernement
j'ajoute que nous allons chercher à
promouvoir plus encore
l'hydroélectricité nous voulons
notamment trouver un nouveau cadre
législatif qui permettra de relancer
rapidement les investissements dans les
barrages sans nécessiter une remise en
concurrence
enfin je veux avoir un mot pour nos
territoires
ultramarins je suis convaincu qu'ils
doivent être aux avant-postes de la
transition écologique et énergétique
grâce aux énergies renouvelables les
outre-mer pourront atteindre l'autonomie
énergétique
mesdames et messieurs les députés en
parallèle nous allons moderniser notre
parc nucléaire
notre premier défi ce sont les réacteurs
existants nous prolongerons tous les
réacteurs qui répondent à nos standards
de sûreté c'est pourquoi EDF conduit
actuellement les études nécessaires avec
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaires pour
identifier les réacteurs qui ne
pourraient pas être prolongés au-delà de
50 ans
ensuite conformément aux engagements du
Président de la République nous avons
nous avons lancé un ambitieux programme
de nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires il
donnera de la visibilité au secteur pour
embaucher et former nos chercheurs
ingénieurs et techniciens de demain
il commence par la construction
il commence par la construction de six
réacteurs EPR 2 dont le premier doit
être mis en service à horizon 2035 le
débat public pour les deux premiers EPR
2 sur le site de panique a été engagé
nous devons faciliter et accélérer le
développement de ses projets notamment
en allégeant certaines procédures
administratives c'est le sens du projet
de loi sur le nucléaire qui a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres le 2
novembre
la seconde étape de notre programme
nucléaire consiste à étudier la
construction de 8 réacteurs
supplémentaires enfin le troisième volet
de notre programme nucléaire c'est
l'innovation pour bâtir des réacteurs de
nouvelles générations la France a pris
des engagements forts ainsi avec France
2030 nous avons décidé d'investir un
milliard d'euros dans le nucléaire du
futur notamment pour la construction
d'un prototype d'un prototype de SMS les
petits réacteurs modulaires en moins de
10 ans
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
dernier axe de notre stratégie c'est
l'investissement dans les vecteurs
énergétiques d'avenir notamment
l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène c'est à la fois une
transition énergétique et industrielle
il va permettre une décarbonation
massive de notre économie même dans les
secteurs les plus consommateurs et les
plus émetteurs comme la sidérurgie ou
les mobilités lourdes l'hydrogène c'est
aussi une opportunité économique avec
une filière nouvelle et sans à 150 000
emplois à la clé c'est enfin une carte
maîtresse pour notre souveraineté nous
voulons faire de la France le leader de
l'hydrogène décarbonée nous investissons
massivement pour y parvenir
9 milliards d'euros dans les prochaines
années notamment grâce à France 2030
si j'évoque l'hydrogène ce n'est
évidemment pas la seule filière dont
nous accompagnons le développement la
décarbonation de notre économie et de
nos quotidiens s'appuiera également sur
la géothermie la biomasse les
biocarburants et le biogaz
je veux dire un mot justement du biogaz
nous sommes lucides et nous savons que
certaines industries ne pourront pas
tout électrifier et auront toujours
besoin de gaz le biogaz sera alors le
meilleur levier pour décarboner
il bénéficiera aussi à notre économie et
à nos territoires c'est une chance pour
nous agriculteurs qui pourront y trouver
une source de revenus complémentaires
tout en valorisant leurs déchets et en
produisant des engrais naturels
c'est une opportunité pour le
développement économique de nos
territoires ruraux en créant des emplois
locaux et non délocalisables c'est
pourquoi nous nous sommes fixés des
objectifs ambitieux de développement de
la méthanisation des mesures pour en
faciliter et en accélérer le déploiement
on d'orait déjà été prise et d'autres
vous sont proposés dans le projet de loi
sur les énergies renouvelables
mesdames et messieurs les députés notre
transition énergétique passe par une
stratégie nationale ambitieuse mais elle
devrait être construite et menée avec
l'Union européenne
bien sûr il peut y avoir des débats car
les situations sont très différentes
d'un pays à l'autre mais nous sommes
convaincus que nous serons plus forts à
cette échelle dans un marché et des
enjeux qui se règle à l'échelle mondiale
l'Union européenne nous permettra
d'aller plus vite et de gagner plus
efficacement notre indépendance lors de
la présidence française du Conseil de
l'Union européenne nous avons réalisé
des étapes majeures au cours du sommet
de Versailles les 27 sont tombés
d'accord pour sortir au plus vite de
notre dépendance aux hydrocarbures
russes et pour accélérer notre sortie
des énergies fossiles cet historique
nous sortirons du gaz et du charbon
grâce à l'Europe c'est aussi avec elle
que nous ferons baisser plus fortement
et plus rapidement notre empreinte
carbone
mesdames et messieurs les députés comme
beaucoup de groupes l'avaient demandé et
comme je m'y étais engagé je viens de
vous présenter les grandes orientations
de la stratégie énergétique de la France
une stratégie claire organisée une
stratégie à tous les niveaux qui
s'incarnera au plus près des territoires
et se lancera en Europe 1 une stratégie
qui nous donne les moyens d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone bien sûr le sujet se
prête aux discussions aux échanges et
parfois même aux patients je suis
impatiente de mener le débat avec vous
mais avant de vous laisser la parole je
souhaiterais partager deux convictions
la première c'est que nous allons vivre
mieux grâce à la transition énergétique
bien sûr des changements rapides
s'engage ils peuvent paraître
vertigineux pour certains de nos
concitoyens nous devons les accompagner
les rassurer
la décarbonation et la sobriété vont
nous protéger des crises à venir elle
permettront de mieux maîtriser les prix
elles seront synonymes de justice
sociale car chacun contribuera selon ses
moyens et nous aiderons ceux dont les
modes de vie et de travail seront les
plus impactés
ma seconde conviction c'est que la
transition énergétique va de pair avec
la croissance et la création d'emplois
elle va accompagner la
réindustrialisation et permettre
l'émergence de secteurs et de filières
d'avenir elle va permettre des
innovations qui bénéficieront à la
société tout entière alors oui la
transition énergétique est un défi mais
c'est aussi une chance nous devons le
saisir et le mener ensemble nous en
sommes capables nous avons tout pour
réussir je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole
la parole est à Madame Julie Leroy pour
le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mes chers collègues les
scientifiques alertent depuis plus de 30
ans sur le réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un mur un
mur qui s'est construit par notre
obsession à penser que nous pouvions
tout contrôler y compris les ressources
naturelles le contexte international de
guerre en Ukraine et la crise
énergétique actuelle qui n'est qu'une
première secousse de la crise climatique
qui s'accélère dangereusement a remis en
exergue les failles de notre imprévision
et de notre immense fragilité
aujourd'hui la situation est la suivante
les prix de l'énergie s'envolent les
Françaises et les Français vont avoir
froid cet hiver la précarité énergétique
augmente des services publics vont
fermer des entreprises risques de mettre
la clé sous la porte et les impacts du
réchauffement climatique sont nettement
tangibles pour chacun et chacune cette
situation n'est autre que la conséquence
de notre éternelle politique débriété
énergétiques alimenter d'une part par
une addiction aux énergies fossiles
importées et d'autre part par un
aveuglement et entêtement délétère dans
le nucléaire
aller briété énergétique nous vous
répondons sobriété tous les
scientifiques qui nous alertaient hier
sur la réalité du réchauffement
climatique converge la réduction de nos
consommations et donc celle de nos
factures est le premier levier de
transition énergétique et de sécurité
énergétique une action massive et
résolue sur les bâtiments et les
logements d'une part sur les transports
et les déplacements de l'autre nous
n'avons plus le luxe madame la Première
ministre de s'enfermer dans une
idéologie du toujours plus de refuser de
faire les investissements nécessaires
dans la planification écologique il nous
faut un véritable plan Marshall dans la
rénovation des bâtiments et des
logements c'était le sens de la
proposition de ma collègue evassas
adopter démocratiquement dans cette
enceinte et plébisciter par la société
civile et tous les scénarios des experts
seul ce choc d'investissement chiffré
par des experts à 29 milliards d'euros
annuels
nous permettra d'y arriver
comme nous l'avons déjà fait dans les
années 70 pour le nucléaire
devenons champion d'une filière
industrielle de la rénovation
création d'emploi formation des artisans
travail avec le secteur du BTP pour
créer une véritable filière durable et
essentielle c'est le seul bouclier
soutenable et
structurelle qu'il protégera tous les
ménages tous nos services publics et nos
TPE PME face à la volatilité des prix
sur les transports nous sommes toujours
soumis à la dépendance à la voiture
individuelle au pétrole et donc à la
spéculation des marchés vous suivez
l'utilisation de la voiture thermique de
manière inconditionnelle et
indifférencier sans tenir compte des
utilisations et des disparités sociales
colossales un choix dispendieux qui
profite au plus riche et maintient les
plus précaires dans la vulnérabilité
face à la hausse des carburants
remplacer les véhicules individuels
thermiques par des véhicules individuels
électriques ne suffira pas nous
consommerons toujours la même quantité
d'énergie et les plaies plus précaires
seront laissées pour compte vous avez
vous-même évoqué l'objectif de diminuer
de 40% de nos consommations énergétiques
d'ici 2050 comment le ferons-nous sans
nous attaquer à la sobriété dans les
transports les solutions là encore nous
les avons déploiement massif des
transports en commun sur tous les
territoires du train du quotidien des
mobilités douces il nous faut là aussi
un choc pour les transports pour donner
une réelle alternative à la voiture
individuelle pour toutes celles et ceux
qui ne peuvent pas s'en passer
aujourd'hui
à cette sobriété vous n'aurez torguez et
briété et nucléaire faire croire aux
Français qu'ils auront avec le nucléaire
accès à une énergie peu coûteuse est un
mensonge et vous le savez il faudra
minimum 15 ans pour pouvoir espérer
construire un nouveau réacteur est-ce
que ça serait un EP R2 un EPR 3 est-ce
qu'on utilisera de l’uranium 235 238
Flamanville est un échec cuisant qui
nous coûte excusez-moi du terme un
pognon de dingue et pendant 15 ans on
fait quoi madame la Première ministre
pour les factures d'électricité on prie
on croit de manière infaillible à la
filière du nucléaire qui sauvera la
crise énergétique et la facture des
Françaises et des Français la moitié de
notre parc aujourd'hui est à l'arrêt
nous sommes le 16 novembre EDF s'était
engagé à rouvrir tous les réacteurs
pendant cet hiver
ou en sommes-nous de ces promesses
vous parlez de deux jambes en matière de
confiance
les deux jambes la sobriété les énergies
renouvelables et
excusez-moi je vais je vais revenir
simplement conclure revenez à la raison
Madame la Présidente le temps est compté
mais les solutions sont là cela fait des
années qu'expert scientifique chef
d'entreprise élu locaux responsables
associatif éprouve ces solutions alors
madame la Première ministre ne vous
laissez pas enfermer dans vos carcans
idéologiques les solutions du passé le
nourrir
faites preuve de courage et de
responsabilité non non merci
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Jumel
pour le groupe GDR
pour une durée de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la première pardon madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
ministre mes chers collègues
engagés un débat sur la politique
énergétique de la France
figure imposée par la situation de crise
que nous traversons
c'est répondre de notre point de vue à
des questions majeures dans lesquelles
les politiques énergétiques jouent un
rôle central
protéger le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
assurer la souveraineté énergétique de
la France qui est indissociable de la
souveraineté industrielle être
évidemment à la hauteur de l'urgence
climatique or ce débat souffre dans un
contexte géopolitique bouleversé par la
guerre où la France et l'Union
européenne se retrouvent confrontés à
une contradiction insurmontable
le dogme de la concurrence libre et non
faussée auquel vous souscrivez ne permet
pas la régulation la concurrence libre
et non faussée non sécure ne sécurise
pas
l'approvisionnement énergétique elle
affaiblit notre souveraineté et se
révèle incapable de prendre soin de la
planète nous considérons pour notre part
et j'y reviendrai que l'énergie n'est
pas une marchandise qu'elle est un bien
de première nécessité un bien commun
même ce qui implique que nos outils de
production quels qu'ils soient nucléaire
ENR échappe à la logique du marché
cette crise les fragilités qu'elle
révèle ne date pas d'hier cette crise
dépasse en rappeler le choc pétrolier de
1973 qui avait entraîné la
multiplication par 4 du prix du pétrole
brut et conduit le gouvernement Messmer
de l'époque avec une forme de courage et
de volontarisme politique
établir un véritable plan stratégique
d'indépendance énergétique puisant ça
sève chez ceux qui dont le sang le
larmes l'espoir de la Libération avait
créé EDF GDF en 1946 la hausse du prix
du gaz naturel et donc de l'électricité
ne date pas d'hier ces prix sont vous le
savez la conséquence du développement du
marché de gros rendu nécessaire par
votre choix d'ouverture à la concurrence
ainsi dans le marché construit à
l'échelle européenne avec des mixes de
production différents les prix dépendent
de la volatilité des énergies
renouvelables des prix du gaz fossile et
de la tonne de CO2
je vous le dis
tranquillement mais fermement
prétendre faire entendre la voix de la
France et d'art qu'elle n'a plus le
contrôle de ses tarifs d'électricité est
une pluridusion elle est même une pure
hypocrisie il faudrait de notre point de
vue au contraire s'émanciper du dogme la
concurrence si l'on veut se donner les
moyens de reprendre la main l'actualité
révèle d'une manière brutale d'une
manière exacerbée ce que nous dénonçons
avec les représentants syndicaux
électriciens Gazi depuis longtemps les
défaillances de notre politique
énergétique et démontre sans effort les
limites du tout marché comme toujours le
discours était bien rodé l'ouverture
totale devait renforcer les droits des
consommateurs et même favoriser
l'innovation industrielle le résultat
vous le connaissez il est sans appel les
dispositifs déployés pour permettre aux
nouveaux entrants de pénétrer le marché
on favoriser l'émergence d'acteurs qui
sont devenus des spécialistes de l'achat
opportuniste
à travers de mécanismes délétères de la
reine pratiquant des marchés abusifs
accumulant les pratiques commerciales
trompeuses et siphonnant par la même
occasion non seulement EDF au plan
financier mais siphonnant EDF dans ses
capacités de savoir-faire et
d'investissement d'avenir vous avez trop
longtemps fermé les yeux sur tout cela
vous avez dès le début renoncé agir vous
êtes vous les libéraux collectivement
responsable de ce processus de
dérèglementation à l'origine de
l'explosion des prix de la remise en
cause de notre indépendance énergétique
à tel point que notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement anxiogène pour notre
économie réelle et nos industries et
questionner alors où je vous parle la
veille de l'hiver la commission
d'enquête initiée par mon collègue le
président marlex c'est présidé par
Raphaël Schlumberger permettra
d'identifier sur le temps long
les responsabilités et les choix
politiques qui ont mené à ce fiasco je
le redoute j'ose même l'anticiper elle
n'épargneront pas grand monde
cette enquête ni la droite ni la gauche
molle
dès le début des années 2000 en effet
EDF
et nous avions perçu la falaise qui se
détachait à l'horizon 2000 comme la
retraite de ses plus anciens réacteurs
construits à partir de 1977 mais je vous
rassure madame la Première ministre
cette commission d'enquête ne vous
épargnera pas non plus
votre politique de flottement votre
politique mi chèvre Michou où selon les
interlocuteurs les effets de mode les
échéances électorales vous avez imposé à
notre fleuron industriel EDF et ses
agents souvent variables d'ajustements
des injonctions contradictoires réduire
des coûts maintenir des prix bas nourrir
et même gaver les concurrents gérer vos
raccompagner le déclin du nucléaire
fermeture de Fessenheim à Red Astrid
fermeture de 14 réacteurs qui sont
encore inscrits dans la PPE aujourd'hui
sont considérations des territoires des
habitants des Travailleurs de la mer
pour l'éolien offshore son véritable
structuration à part pour l'éolien
offshore je le concept sans véritable
structuration pour le photovoltaïque ni
le lien à terre de filières
industrielles made in France tout cela
en laissant son venimés pardon les
relations entre filiales Areva EDF
accréditant l'idée d'une guerre sans cap
sans tête perdant chaque jour un peu
plus de ses savoir-faire et contraintes
d'aller chercher à l'étranger a pris
exorbitant la validation de ces concepts
techniques le gouvernement s'étonne
aujourd'hui du manque de réactivité de
DF sur la question de des corrosion sous
contraintes faisant semblant d'ignorer
les particularités y compris du temps de
travail des interventions en centrales
et faisant surtout l'impasse et le
député normand que je suis mesure cela
comme un enjeu stratégique de la perte
de savoir-faire du besoin de main
d'oeuvre de la perte de savoir-faire
révéler faute de stratégie globale et
cohérente dans le même temps l'Allemagne
au nom d'une prétendue écologique fermée
ses réacteurs renforcer sa dépendance au
gaz russe faisait tourner à plein ces
centrales à charbon tout en faisant la
loi au sein de la Commission européenne
la suite la suite vous la connaissez
elle est sous nos yeux 13 millions de
précaires énergétiques 84% des Français
qui considèrent cette question comme une
préoccupation majeure les villes de
France confrontées à l'explosion des
factures qui fragilisent nos services
publics et chez moi l'économie réelle
bousculée les verriers verres sens
pocher du corval l'agroalimentaire
Danone les ateliers du goût davigel ou
bien encore l'automobile avec alpine
sont confrontés à une fragilisation de
leur compétitivité industrielle face à
l'explosion du prix que votre bouclier
pour l'instant ne permet pas de contenir
je veux terminer mon propos en indiquant
que les députés communistes le groupe
GDR ne se contentent pas de pointer du
doigt vos responsabilités votre absence
de cohérence pour l'avenir mais inverse
également au débat des propositions
réfléchies grâce à l'intelligence
ouvrière grâce à l'intelligence des
acteurs de terrain grâce à ce qui est
depuis longtemps s'intéresse au sujet je
pense notamment c'est au cézec ces
propositions nous les portons
aujourd'hui devant vous suspendre la
reine au titre des circonstances
exceptionnelles prévues dans le code de
l'énergie adapter le tarif réglement le
ventre de l'électricité à la réalité du
mix production français en incluant la
production hydraulique resterait le
tarif réglementé de vente pour les
collectivités territoriales pour les
entreprises et évidemment le maintenir
pour les ménages instaurer une TVA 5
pour ce bien commun de première
nécessité et enfin engager une réelle
une réelle une véritable pas une fausse
renationalisation d'EDF et d'engie au
statut des pics nous le savons et vous
le savez la remontée au capital d'EDF
engagé par l'État sans modification du
statut de société anonyme vous permet
quand vous voulez sans le Parlement de
revenir avec votre mauvais projet de
vente à la découpe un Hercule 2.0 qui
viendrait parachever votre vision
libérale l'inversion du calendrier
parlementaire l'accélération des
honneurs peut être d'ailleurs au service
de cette vente à la découpe d'EDF pour
que les choses soient claires les nerfs
pour le groupe communiste l'énergie la
moins chère c'est celle qui n'est pas
consommée il y a donc des efforts
colossaux à réaliser pour la sobriété
énergétique votre fut réitérer dans le
PLF de donner des moyens à la rénovation
thermique de donner les moyens au
développement des lignes ferroviaires du
quotidien et l'illustration d'un
contre-sens historique si l'on consomme
moins et mieux et c'est nécessaire si
l'on anticipe l'après pétrole et ça
devient urgent il y a nécessité et nous
sommes favorables à ça à construire un
mix énergétique équilibré intelligent
dans lequel les EnR ont leur place mais
pour les EnR pas n'importe où pas
n'importe comment pas avec n'importe qui
et surtout passons les gens passant les
mers passant le respect des territoires
l'absence sur cette question
essentielle du renouvellement de nos
capacités de production des
investissements nécessaires pour le
nucléaire et l'absence dans votre propos
des modalités de financement hypothèques
la visibilité de la stratégie de l'État
dans ce domaine je termine pour faire
tout cela il faut de la régulation par
la puissance public pour faire tout cela
ça nécessite de ne pas laisser de
marcher faire son œuvre pour faire tout
ça il faut préserver l'unicité
d'intégrité des outils industriels de la
production à la distribution tout cela
implique tout cela implique madame la
Présidente c'est la dernière phrase tout
cela implique que nous reprenions à
notre compte la phrase prononcée par
l'énergie ouvrière du ministre Marcel
Paul dans cette émission si nous avons
une vision d'ensemble de ces problèmes
alors nous acterons que l'énergie c'est
l'arme
utile pour la reprise économique je vous
remercie de votre attention je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin sainte
huile du groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues le groupe liotte interviendra
en deux temps je laisserai mon collègue
maxiassin revenir sur les questions
liées aux problématiques notamment
ultramarines et des territoires
interconnectés
madame la Première ministre vous l'avez
dit dans votre propos le contexte actuel
impose quasiment à la représentation
nationale et au gouvernement que vous
pilotez de poser les jalons du débat sur
la question
énergétique le conflit
ukrainien engagé par la folie de
Vladimir Poutine les impacts immédiats
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat qui
impose une austérité que les Français
n'ont pas souhaité le dérèglement
climatique que nous avons vécu plus
particulièrement et plus brutalement
encore cet été conduit les uns et les
autres effectivement à se poser la
question alors si le débat est légitime
nécessaire à ce je venais en moins
revenir sur la méthode
le groupe IOT regrette que nous n'ayons
pas saisi l'occasion de ce contexte
extraordinaire pour anticiper la PPE la
proposition plus réelle sur l'énergie
qui est prévu pour 2023 et qui aurait
permis à la représentation nationale et
au gouvernement d'essayer de fixer
ensemble les objectifs que nous
cherchons à atteindre collectivement en
effet si nous le disons avec clarté les
textes qui sont devant nous ils vont
venir fixer un cap qui eut justifier une
discussion préalable qui ne se
limiterait pas à une soirée ou demeurant
sympathique mais une soirée courte sur
ces questions énergétiques pour
permettre à chacune et chacun d'entre
nous de construire des perspectives qui
je le crois peuvent être partagées par
une majorité large sur ses bancs en
effet
vous l'avez dit le président de la
République a déjà fixé des jalons qui
encadrent en quelque sorte ce que nous
avons à construire ensemble ou plus
exactement ce que vous avez décidé que
nous allions en construire pourquoi je
dis ça parce que aujourd'hui on a ce
débat à quelques jours de la discussion
sur la sur les e NR que portera madame
panier une hachée et la discussion au
Sénat a déjà eu lieu le discours de
Belfort a fixé la stratégie que vous
avez rappelé dans votre propos et donc
également par la même fixer le cap de ce
que le gouvernement imagine sur le champ
du nucléaire et donc nous nous
retrouvons dans cette situation de
méthodologie un peu surprenante où nous
avons un débat alors que les choses sont
déjà tranchées déjà arrêté et donc je
voulais le dire ici avec beaucoup de
clarté mais en bienveillance nous
aurions que le débat soit plus large à
travers l'anticipation à la PPE puisque
le contexte le justifie largement je
veux revenir à l'instant sur les
perspectives je crois que la question du
mix énergétique pourra faire si pas
uneanimité au moins consensus sur ces
bancs nous nous considérons que au
regard de la demande croissante qui sera
nécessaire pour répondre aux besoins
d'électricité d'ici à 2050 effectivement
il faut pouvoir sortir de la logique de
la théorie et du dogme pour se heurter à
la réalité et cette réalité c'est à la
fois un besoin de travailler sur la
question nucléaire en finesse puisque
notre parc vieilli et que la maintenance
un peu plus longue que prévu en témoigne
sans doute et que par ailleurs nous
avons l'État français
à accepter d'être mauvais élève de la
classe à l'instant à l'échelle
européenne puisque nous avons du plus
tard dans les objectifs qui étaient
fixés et donc clairement le groupe
liotte accompagnera cette logique
pragmatique qui vise à permettre à ce
mix énergétique de pouvoir se développer
il n'en demeure pas moins que si nous
voulons rattraper notre retard sur la
question des ENR il y aura un certain
nombre de sujets que nous devons traiter
ensemble je ne résiste pas à la
tentation de caresser les outre-mer mais
nous y reviendrons et à vous dire
également que sur ces sujets sans doute
sans doute que les effectifs dans les
services compétents notamment de la
Dréal sont un des éléments du problème
pour dénouer une forme d'embouteillage
enfin et pour les quelques secondes qui
me restent ou dire que si nous sommes
absolument favorables à l'accélération
de la transition cela passera sans doute
par des investissements plus importants
que ceux qui ont été fixés jusqu'à ce
stade sur les transports et sur le rail
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion il y a quelques
temps ici même de vous le dire je
termine en vous disant qu'évidemment
nous sommes à la fois attentifs et
peut-être parfois aussi un peu inquiet
de ce que sera l'avenir de EDF et nous
aurons besoin qu'évidemment dans la
perspective d'énergie que nous devons
construire ensemble vous puissiez
clarifier rapidement ce que sont vos
intentions je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel la crèche pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur et mesdames madame et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
certains salariés de l'industrie
concentrent d'énormes sacrifices pour
travailler la nuit et le week-end en ce
moment certains locataires du parc
social font face à des Hauts de charges
justifiées vous venez madame le premier
perspective à ses efforts et un horizon
assez difficile vous avez une méthode la
planification écologique et une
détermination portée notre économie un
niveau de résilience inédit pour établir
la confiance dans notre système
énergétique vous menez une guerre de
souveraineté avec une première bataille
réussie c'est la diversification des
approvisionnements de gaz de batailles
restent à menées celle du nucléaire
il ne faut pas par patient
anti-européenne vouloir revenir des
doctrines dépassées d'une épaule DDF du
tout nucléaire et de la fin du marché
européen vous accomplissez au contraire
dans la voie du discours de Belfort la
négociation d'EDF pour protéger
les financements de projets de long
terme comme celui des Epl déjà aussi le
mécanisme européen des prix de
l'électricité a été modifiée et l'impact
de production des coûts du fossile a été
largement à moins de riz l'autre
bataille qui reste amener et
l'équipement en solaire et on est au
lien marin on sent qu'un pan de
l'écologie est plutôt passé à la
décroissance alors qu'au fur et à mesure
l'état développe une action rationnelle
et assez massive par tous les
préfectures installées des coordinations
des entreprises de connexion dressent
des cartographies des espaces
disponibles mobilisent EPCI grande
surface et fédération agricoles c'est la
planification du territoire des
territoires en coproduction agricoles
énergétique dans une forme d'autonomie
et mieux planifier en amour résiliente
de notre économie énergétique
dans notre assemblée le débat doit se
poursuivre au même rythme que c'est
investissement nous pourrions anticiper
la future programmation énergétique en
menant d'ici à son au débat à ce sujet
de débats financièrement déterminants
d'abord les récents débats de la
commission des finances invite à
anticiper le retour à une situation des
cours plus normaux de l'énergie dans le
programme 345 de la mission écologie
dans l'hypothèse ou la compensation due
énergéticien classique pour les charges
du service public resterait négative des
ressources qui n'auront plus au bouclier
seront disponibles dès l'année prochaine
alors ce pour dessinera un budget de la
production d'énergie celui qu'on
pourrait appeler des deux piliers de
Belfort on pourrait rattacher au
programme 345 les lignes hydrogène la
recherche nucléaire du CA le financement
de la Délégation interministérielle pour
le nouveau client que vous nous
félicitons d'avoir créé le soutien aux
connexions
et le soutien au gros consommateur de
courant nucléaire autrement appelé à
Rennes
préparons à ce sujet une double
révolution en matière de raccordement
électrique celui du tarif et celui du
mode du planification des décisions de
raccordement local
l'organisation internationale de
l'énergie de l'OCDE nous en conjure il
faut produire un ressaut massif
d'investissement en matière de
raccordement transformé RT et enedis une
nouvelle mission prioritaire s'accorde
s'offre à eux après avoir raccordé
l'ensemble du territoire et les
consommateurs il faudrait accorder les
producteurs après une loi d'accélération
nucléaire pourquoi pas une loi
d'accélération des records même si il en
sera question dans la loi d'accélération
des ENR
portons notre attention sur des débats
concrets de projets cadencier
depuis Belfort avec cette crise nous
pouvons être la première économie
développée en 2050 vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure avec des carbonée dans
l'intégralité notre production d'énergie
il serait absurde renoncer à cette
Europe du marché d'électricité
parisiologie protectionniste l'Allemagne
sortira du charbon en 2030 et la Pologne
va retrouver le chemin des financements
du plan de relance européen pour faire
passer 200 000 salariés polonais du
charbon au nucléaire d'ici là notre
avance sera déterminant et ce sera un
avantage ce qui importe aujourd'hui dans
le débat énergétique et l'industrie la
localisation des filières industrielles
mais aussi l'action des bicarbonation
revitalisons d'abord nos industries de
base dans des régions historiquement
industrielles fondeur chaudronnier
usineurs et soudeur viendront des
industries existantes avant toute chose
il faut aussi des alliances
industrielles avec les grandes nations
de la mécanique et du nucléaire aussi
bien les Etats-Unis que l'Italie et
l'est de l'Europe le nucléaire est
depuis toujours une industrie de
coopération internationale avec lequel
nous allons régén probablement le
deuxième parc nucléaire au monde ensuite
décarbonons l'industrie jusqu'à présent
à Bruxelles nous avions des instruments
qu'ils aient l'objet de débat
aujourd'hui le président de la
République des signes un cycle de 18
mois
industriels de revitalisation
l'industrie avec 5 milliards d'euros
immédiatement et peut-être 5 milliards
en suite dans 18 mois il a rappelé
madame la Première ministre que vous
étiez à l'origine de la notion de
programmation écologique lors de la
réunion à l'Elysée qui était une réunion
fondamentale et nous avons senti
l'impact dans tous les territoires dans
les territoires et ici à Bruxelles et
auprès de nos industriels nous redirons
aussi que votre action est unique de
résilience d'autonomie stratégique et de
souveraineté économique je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Philippe Tanguy pour le
rassemblement national
pour 15 minutes
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers collègues
rien dans la vie n'est à craindre tout
doit être compris c'est maintenant le
moment de comprendre davantage afin de
craindre moins si j'ai voulu commencer
cette contribution au débat sur la
politique énergétique par cette citation
de l'immense Marie Curie c'est que nous
avons la conviction cheville au corps
avec Marine Le Pen et le groupe
rassemblement national que la France est
plus largement les civilisations
humaines ont plus que jamais besoin du
savoir du progrès et de la raison pour
affronter les crises dans lequel
l'incompétence l'irrationalité et la
cupidité ont plongé les peuples la peur
comme l'ignorance son mauvaise
conseillère et ne font qu'aggraver les
crises que nous traversons nous voyons
se multiplier à travers l'Occident les
mouvements millénaristes d'extrême
gauche
ivre de la certitude d'incarner le bien
y compris contre la contre la démocratie
contre la majorité des citoyens ils
attaquent nos industries nos
agriculteurs et nos scientifiques
aggravant les délakalisations et donc la
pollution notre dépendance au reste du
monde caricature d'hommes et de
déracinés aveuglé par des idéologies
sans lien avec la réalité les voilà qui
s'attaquent désormais à la culture à
l'art aux œuvres de l'esprit animés
d'une haine pénitentielle contre
l'humanité que nous avons déjà connu
dans notre histoire avec des épreuves
que personne ne souhaite trop vivre
aussi irresponsable et effrayant que
soient ces mouvements il faut
reconnaître qu'ils sont nourris par des
décennies d'échec qu'incarnent
parfaitement la macronie caricature de
ce que Marine Le Pen avait qualifié de
climato hypocrisie depuis des décennies
les gouvernements climato-hypocrites ont
manipulé la juste cause de
l'environnement pour taxer les Français
et justifier la baisse de leur niveau de
vie en parfait climato-hypocrite les
macronistes ont fermé la centrale de
Fessenheim alors qu'elle produisait
autant que tous les panneaux solaires
français
en parfait climato-hypocrite vous avez
accusé le rassemblement national lors de
la présidentielle de vos propres
turpitudes à savoir ouvrir les centrales
à charbon alors que nous ne l'avions
jamais envisagé il est affligent que le
débat public soit si corrompu que le
seul mouvement leur affaire national qui
soit innocent des erreurs qui nous ont
conduit à la catastrophe et qui au
contraire a toujours alerté proposé une
alternative souveraine soit accusée
d'être climato-sceptique ou soumis à je
ne sais quelle influence ce n'est pas le
rassemblement national qui maintenant
depuis 50 ans a maintenu la France dans
la dépendance aux hydrocarbures
utilisant en fait uniquement les taxes
sur le carburant pour tondre les
Français c'est vous ce n'est pas le
rassemblement national qui a rendu
dépendant toute l'Europe au gaz russe au
pétrole des islamistes et aux terres
rares et dictatures emplèrent des
esclaves c'est vous ce n'est pas le
rassemblement national qui a fait
effondrer la production nucléaire de
25%, 20 ans et fait passer la France
d'un pays largement exportateur
d'électricité à un pays importateur
c'est vous cette climato confine au
cynisme quand on incarne à ce point la
mondialisation la marchandisation du
monde le règne de l'argent droit roi qui
détruisent la planète vous couvrez vos
effets économiques et la politique
d'injustice fiscale par des slogans
écologiques et la culpabilisation des
Français vous allez désormais jusqu'à
interdire aux classes populaires et
moyenne de rouler dans leur propre ville
avec les énigmes
les importations en fait représentent
plus de la moitié de l'empreinte carbone
de la France et pourtant le débat
politique en dehors de Marine Le Pen
parle de tout sauf de la fin de la
mondialisation irresponsable et Macron
Emmanuel Macron a participé à une énième
COP dont les objectifs sont louables
mais dans tous les mécanismes échouent
puisque la principale origine du
désordre écologique la mondialisation
n'est jamais mise en cause et pire
encore elle reste présentée comme un
objectif humaniste alors qu'elle est
tout simplement irresponsable et même
suicidaire
voilà maintenant 50 ans que les
mouvements nationaux souverainissent
gaullistes ont averti que la perte de
souveraineté sur nos matières premières
notre alimentation notre énergie et
notre industrie mènerait la catastrophe
nos analyses ont toujours été payées par
la science en particulier les rapports
du Club de Rome dès 1972 alerte sur un
modèle productiviste que la
globalisation et la marchandisation du
monde ne pouvait qu'aggraver les crises
énergétiques économiques et
environnementales se succèdent elles
démontrent que la crise économique et
sociale à la même cause que la crise
écologique énergétique vous êtes et vous
restez aveuglé par l'idéologie
mondialiste vous avez réduit la
politique environnementale à l'écologie
punitive
manipulant cette liste cause pour
multiplier les taxes et les contraintes
contre le peuple pour mieux le
culpabiliser et exonérer les principales
responsabilités celle d'un système
économique unique unique pardon qui
produit à l'autre bout du monde ce que
nous devrions produire chez nous qui
broie les droits sociaux ferment acquis
qui brûlent les précieuses ressources
naturelles sur l'hôtel de l'agent Roy
Jacques Chirac avait bien raison de dire
que tous ceux qui se sont succédés au
pouvoir regardent d'ailleurs alors que
la terre brûle et il aurait pu ajouter
que les peuples s'appauvrissent le débat
public est envahi de dévastériles et de
diversion pour exonérer les principales
responsables du désordre économique et
écologique le nucléaire le nucléaire
meilleur espoir de l'humanité pour
produire une énergie massive sans
carbone gâchant le moindre source et
d'espace public a été accusé de tous les
mots imaginaires pendant que le pétrole
le charbon et le gaz continuer leur
irresponsable ascension depuis la crise
pétrolière des années 1970 qui aurait dû
engager une transition définitive vers
l'électrification de l'industrie du
transport et du Logement les émissions
de CO2 liées aux énergies carbones ont
doublé les classes populaires et
moyennes qui n'ont d'autres moyens que
d'utiliser leur véhicule pour vivre les
ruraux qui n'ont d'autres moyens que se
chauffer que le fioul les agriculteurs
qui se démènent pour nous nourrir ont
été et reste encore aujourd'hui accusés
de tous les mots de la planète pour
éviter le débat principal que nous
aurions avoir tous le changement total
de modèle économique vers la
relocalisation optimale des activités la
souveraineté économique et énergétique
et un aménagement durable notre
territoire ce sont les seuls politiques
garantes d'une prospérité partagée de la
justice sociale et de la préservation de
notre environnement les crises sociales
écologiques atteignent désormais une
gravité qui impose que vous les
regardiez en face à défaut d'être
capable de les résoudre ces crises ont
déjà affaibli le niveau de vie de
concitoyens le pouvoir d'achat c'est
érodé après avoir stagné il est
désormais si affaibli qu'un nombre
toujours plus grand de familles renonce
à se chauffer à visiter leurs proches et
même maintenant à se nourrir sainement
alors qu'elles ont fondé notre
démocratie sociale la prospérité de nos
économies est la stabilité de notre
modèle le travail et les valeurs
cardinales qui lui sont attachées ne
garantissent plus de pouvoir vivre
dignement le spectre du revenu de
subsistance que d'autres veulent
désormais renommer le salaire universel
revient en thé le débat économique et
les économies envoient de tiers
mondialisation depuis plusieurs
générations les grands-parents puis les
parents des classes moyennes et
populaires s'inquiétaient que leurs
enfants vivent moins bien que même
désormais ce sont ces enfants et ses
petits-enfants qui s'interrogent sur la
survie même de tout ce que tout ce que
nous pensions avoir acquis par des
générations de travail et de sacrifices
les sociétés européennes en particulier
la société française vit dans l'angoisse
d'un avenir fait de pénuries de
restrictions et de régression quand
elles ne se demande pas si
l'environnement n'aura pas été si
dégradé qu'il provoquera une catastrophe
mondiale vous avez décidé de faire de
cet angoisse l'angoisse de la pénurie un
objectif politique c'est ce que vous
venez d'annoncer dans votre discours
dans un retournement machiavélique inouï
vous présentez les sacrifices et les
manquements comme un nouvel horizon de
la civilisation en réalité cette
stratégie n'est pas une politique vous
êtes acculé par vos échecs vous êtes
acculés par la perte de notre
souveraineté énergétique vous êtes
acculé par la paire de notre
souveraineté alimentaire et industrielle
ce gouvernement subit la crise sans
avoir la moindre idée de comment la
résoudre et pire vous continuez à
refuser voir à ricaner visiblement des
idées du rassemblement national pour les
résoudre croire que la crise écologique
sociale économique pourra se résoudre
par la pénurie et la restriction est une
hérésie en affirmant qu'il faut que les
Français choisissent la sobriété
énergétique vous sous-entendez que de
compatriotes sera en état d'hybriété
énergétique que nous consommerions trop
d'énergie et trop de richesses un tel
diagnostic montre votre aveuglement nos
compatriotes y compris les classes
moyennes ce sacrifie et se restreignent
depuis des années jamais la pauvreté
jamais la précarité énergétique n'a été
aussi forte avez-vous déjà oublié la
révolte des gilets jaunes traduisant à
quel point les Français étaient déjà au
bout des efforts qu'ils peuvent fournir
l'énergie n'est pas un bien comme un
autre elle est le cœur battant de
l'économie et des sociétés humaines
toute l'aventure humaine est une quête
sans cesse renouvelée pour la maîtrise
des ressources naturelles la maîtrise
des lois de la physique qui lui
permettent et nous permet de prospérer
l'ensemble des révolutions productives
de l'humanité des plus anciennes au plus
contemporaines ont tout été fondées sur
la maîtrise d'une ou plusieurs formes
d'énergie ces acquis technologiques se
sont tous leur cumulés et ne se sont
jamais remplacés l'humanité en réalité
toujours besoin de plus d'énergie pour
améliorer ces conditions de vie soulager
la dureté du travail conquérir de
nouveaux territoires et désormais la
mère et l'espace le choix du modèle
énergétique que nous faisons
conditionnera notre rapport au monde les
ressources naturelles ne sont pas et ne
seront jamais réparties équitablement
sur terre plus elles sont rares plus
elles seront aprement disputées la crise
du covid a rompu l'illusion que la
mondialisation vous offrir des richesses
au monde entier à la moindre tension les
pays dépendants se retrouvent dépourvus
à la pays à la merci pardon des pays
autonomes pour ne pas dire des pays
hégémoniques la mondialisation heureuse
a vécu et nous sommes renvoyés à la
triste réalité ne sont libres que les
peuples qui maîtrisent leurs ressources
vitales qu'avons-nous oublier des
racines de notre civilisation quand les
cités grecques refusaient de citer de
céder à l'envahisseur Perse l'eau et la
terre symbole de leur liberté face à la
soumission choisir la dépendance comme
l’ont fait les gouvernements français
depuis 30 ans au mépris de l'héritage du
général de Gaulle nos amis dans une
impasse entraînant une facture
énergétique économique que les Français
paient de plus en plus lourdement
particulièrement conscient de notre
dépendance et de nos pauvreté naturelle
le général de Gaulle avait perçu que les
crises pétrolières que la France après
les crises pétrolières que la France
devait produire sa propre énergie et
dans la mesure du possible un maximum de
ressources nous nous sommes donc engagés
dans la plus grande révolution
énergétique de pays Occident je l'ai
fait le plan Messmer 58 réacteurs
nucléaires construit en seulement 30 ans
à partir du fait divers industriel
naissante jusqu'à 6 et même huit
réacteurs par an ce sont ce succès ce
plan Messmer la France a inventé la
première croissance verte la France est
enrichie en produisant 75% de son
électricité avec le nucléaire 15 % avec
l'hydroélectricité 90% de son énergie
sans émission c'est ça le modèle qu'il
faut tenir voilà notre proposition il
faut renouer avec ce qu'il y a marché
[Applaudissements]
le plan de Belfort d'Emmanuel Macron n'a
jamais été un plan de relance nucléaire
l'objectif de 50% du nucléaire dans le
micellaire électrique n'a pas changé
vous mentez aux français quand vous
dites que vous avez renoué avec le
nucléaire rien n'est prévu de plus de ce
qui était déjà prévu à savoir la
décroissance du nucléaire et pire la
décroissance maintenue de notre
industrie rien dans votre plan ne permet
de réindustrialiser la France et donc de
décarboner l'économie vous avez signé le
traité de Paris vous êtes déjà incapable
de le respecter car 50% des émissions
50% de notre empreinte carbone c'est les
importations tant que vous ne serez pas
affronté aux importations vous
continuerez à faire souffrir les
français pour rien pour rien et pour
jamais rien vous n'avez rien d'autre à
proposer que doubler les éoliennes qui
n'a jamais marché vous n'avez rien
d'autre à proposer que décupler les
panneaux solaires pour enrichir
l'industrie l'industrie chinoise vous
n'avez rien d'autre à proposer que 50
parcs éoliennes en mer dont personne ne
veut ce qu'il faut c'est relancer la
seule filière qui est fait ses preuves
la filière nucléaire
nous voulons concentrer les efforts de
réindustrialisation de la France sur la
filière nucléaire contrairement aux
mensonges de la présidentielle que vous
avez affirmé et réaffirmé la filière
nucléaire française si on lui redonne
les moyens et parfaitement capables de
refaire ce qu'elle a déjà fait il faut
donc relancer immédiatement au moins la
construction de 20 apres de et pas
seulement de 6 avant 2040 il faut
parallèlement lancer la recherche et
l'aboutissement d'un réacteur de
quatrième génération capable de recycler
les déchets pourquoi il faut ça parce
qu'il faut produire suffisamment
d'énergie c'est une fois que nous aurons
la garantie d'avoir suffisamment
d'électricité que nous pourrons produire
l'hydrogène pour décarboner l'industrie
et ce n'est pas dans le sens inverse
c'est seulement quand nous aurons
suffisamment d'électricité que nous
pourrons relocaliser l'industrie pour
repasser de 10 à 20% d'industrie dans le
PIB c'est-à-dire le niveau que nous
avions dans les années 90 c'est
seulement avec suffisamment
d'électricité que nous pouvons alimenter
les pompes valeur qui sont qui sont en
accord avec la rénovation des logements
sans pompe à chaleur rénover les
logements ne sert à rien vous serez
toujours dépendants des énergies
carbones enfin c'est seulement en
produisant suffisamment d'électricité
qu'on peut imaginer un jour se passer du
pétrole mais pour le moment les options
vous mettez sur la table ne vont
n’amener qu'à l'échec et qu'à la
pauvrissement des Français vous l'avez
compris nous n'avons pas du tout la même
ambition que vous nous ne pensons pas
que faire souffrir les Français va
sauver la planète nous ne pensons pas
qu'à pas ouvrir la France va sauver la
planète nous pensons au contraire quand
nos promettant que des pénuries et des
restrictions français vous allez tout
droit à la catastrophe car l'humanité ne
peut pas s'appauvrir plus vous promettez
à l'humanité de sa provenir moins elle
choisira la voix du progrès et de la
décarbonation c'est ce qui échoue depuis
20 ans et vous ne tirez aucune
conséquence de l'échec des coques vous
ne tirez aucune conséquence de l'échec
de la décarbonation de l'économie
mondiale depuis maintenant 20 ans vous
l'avez compris et je reviendrai à Marie
Curie le rassemblement national est
désormais le seul mouvement qui croit
rapport à la science et au progrès
humain c'est la science et le progrès
humain qui a permis à l'humanité d'être
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui c'est la
science et le progrès humain qui ont
permis la garantie des libertés
individuelles et c'est la science et le
progrès humain dont la France a été la
championne pendant des années pendant
des siècles qui permettra à notre pays
de retrouver sa grandeur
je vous remercie
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Marleix
président du groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame le
Premier ministre mes chers collègues
le président de la République s'est fait
élire il y a
plus de 6 ans la première fois en
faisant rêver les Français sur la
start-up nation et les Français
découvrent aujourd'hui avec stupéfaction
qu'ils devront peut-être retrouver des
bougies pour s'éclairer cet hiver quel
échec quel échec que votre politique
menait depuis au moins cinq années pour
ce qui concerne le chef de l'État et en
réalité un peu plus puisqu'il était
auparavant ministre de l'Économie
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là à
cause de deux grands abandons le premier
c'est celui de notre filière nucléaire
madame le Premier ministre cet
abonnement cet abandon de la filière
nucléaire alors que nous avions un
leader un leadership mondial dans le
domaine du nucléaire il a été décidé à
l'occasion d'un accord électoral de
novembre 2001 entre deux formations
politiques sur la gauche de l'hémicycle
avec un espèce de dit le circonscription
contre central nucléaire et cet accord
politique s'attaquent électoral honteux
de novembre 2011 madame la Première
ministre si vous n'avez pas la mémoire
très précise
cet accord électoral vous ne l'avez pas
remis en cause et depuis que le
Président Macron dirige le pays il ne
l'a pas remis en cause il l'a appliqué à
la lettre scrupuleusement il a appliqué
à la lettre en fermant Fessenheim il a
appliqué à la lettre en annonçant dans
un discours en novembre 2018 la
fermeture de 14 réacteurs nucléaires et
à l'heure où nous parlons madame le
Premier ministre dans la loi française
il est toujours question de fermer 12
réacteurs nucléaires derrière c'est
toute une filière que vous avez des
mobilisé que vous avez démotivé ce qui
explique en grande partie mais pas
seulement le covid les difficultés qu'il
y a aujourd'hui à assumer les travaux
d'entretien de maintenance sur le parc
nucléaire français quand on vend
notamment Alstom algi il ne faut pas
s'étonner que derrière il y a des
difficultés d'entretien sur centrale
nucléaire la France se retrouve donc
condamné à revivre son histoire puisque
c'est le plan Messmer effectivement qui
nous avait en réponse à la crise
pétrolière au premier choc pétrolier de
1973 qui avait décidé d'armer la France
en matière d'indépendance énergétique et
puisque nous avons oublié cette promesse
puisque vous avez oublié cette promesse
la France redécouvre les pénuries
d'électricité auxquelles nous avions à
l'époque décidé de répondre je dis nous
puisque c'était les gaulliste qui
dirigeait le pays à cette époque la
deuxième la deuxième trahise je me
souviens pas que Pierre Messmer et
jamais soutenu le Front national la
deuxième la deuxième trahison c'est
celle de votre absence de projet
pour pour notre championnat qui était
EDF EDF jusqu'à il y a peu c'était le
premier énergéticien mondiale la
première entreprise de fabrication
d'électricité dans le monde nous avions
un championnat national jusqu'à il y a
deux ou trois ans aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le cas pourquoi parce que le seul
projet que l'État actionnaires a eu
depuis 5 ans pour l'entreprise EDF ça a
été son démantèlement nous avions une
entreprise intégrée capable de produire
de l'électricité l'électricité nucléaire
de l'électricité hydroélectrique mais
mais aussi de transporter l'électricité
et puis une entreprise de services
derrière enedis et bien votre seul
projet aura été de faire travailler
l'entreprise depuis cinq ans sur un
projet de démantèlement de démembrement
de cette entreprise qui est très
clairement pour tous les spécialistes
qui ont examiné ce dossier un projet de
banquier d'affaires et certainement pas
un projet industriel alors oui nous
avons aujourd'hui sur vos ambitions pour
EDF et j'espère que nous aurons des
réponses notre collègue Philippe Brun a
lancé une alerte sur ce qui était vos
projets le nouveau président de
directeur général de DF c'est engagé à
ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'Hercule 2 nous
entendons des engagements très précis de
votre part ce soir les conséquences de
ces abandons nous les connaissons les
Français les connaissent les entreprises
les connaissent c'est d'abord une
situation de crise pour pour les
entreprises vous avez mis en place vous
l'avez rappelé des mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement incompréhensibles
pour les entreprises à l'heure qu'il est
aucune entreprise n'a compris ce que
vous vouliez faire madame le Premier
ministre avec votre dispositif
d'amortisseur personne n'a compris
qu'elle serait le niveau des aides avec
les guichets que vous voulez mettre en
place et d'après les premières éléments
de comparaison qu'on a la seule
certitude qu'on est c'est que
l'entreprise que continueront de payer
les PME français sera vraisemblablement
deux fois plus cher que l'on trouve que
le que le prix de l'électricité payé par
les Allemands les Allemands ont mis en
place un système très énergique très
efficace plafonnement du prix de
l'électricité à 130 euros le Megawatt
jusqu'à 70% de la consommation et après
le prix du marché malheureusement votre
système est beaucoup moins efficace nous
avons la faiblesse de penser de
continuer à penser que la seule solution
c'était de s'extraire du marché européen
même si effectivement notre manque
d'indépendance aujourd'hui rendez-moi
évident moins facile
la demande d'une d'une dérogation
européenne de type de type de celles
qu'on a obtenu l'Espagne et le Portugal
le coût d'un plafonnement du gaz utilisé
pour produire de l'électricité en France
ce serait élevé sur cette année environ
à 5 milliards c'était donc sans doute
une solution moins coûteuse que celle
que vous allez mettre en place et
infiniment plus efficace pour nos
entreprises ensuite la question des
particuliers là encore vous vous vantez
de plafonner l'augmentation à 15% mais
15% c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup pour
beaucoup de nos compatriotes aux modeste
au revenu moyen puisque pour un couple
qui chauffe un pavillon équipé 3000
euros par an d'électricité c'est pas une
facture d'un prix extravagant et bien ça
fera 450 euros de plus à la fin du mois
sur on augmente de 15 %. donc ce chiffre
malheureusement il est important et là
aussi si on avait eu un peu de courage
un peu de volonté politique on aurait pu
suspendre l'application de la loi norme
qui qui impacte qui fait que le prix du
gaz oui mais non madame elle a été votée
à une époque il n'y avait pas de crise
de prix du gaz et on a le droit de
savoir un peu s'adapter c'est même le
rôle des gouvernants
deuxième sujet dans votre gouvernement
ne parle de par le pas c'est la question
du prix du gaz pour nos concitoyens la
question de nos prix du gaz puisque le
tarif réglementé du gaz va prendre fin
au mois de juin 2023 juin 2023 c'est
dans 6 mois vous nous sommes en train
d'adopter une loi de finance à ce jour
rien n'est prévu qu'avez-vous à dire à
nos concitoyens sur ce sujet alors
ensuite comment on sort de cette de
cette situation que vous avez que vous
avez créé d'abord en commençant par le
commencement madame le Premier ministre
il est absolument invraisemblable que
nous commençons par un petit axe sur les
EnR ensuite un texte sur le nucléaire et
on terminera enfin par une programmation
plurauelle de l'électricité de l'énergie
il aurait fallu deux tout évidence
commencer par ce texte sur la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
pour savoir de quel besoin d'énergie et
de quel besoin d'électricité nous allons
avoir besoin dans l'avenir
malheureusement tant de choses
aberrantes ont été dites ont été écrites
ces dernières années je ne remets pas en
cause le travail de RTL qui est un
travail assez rigoureux mais je fais
allusion à des travaux de la dame je me
souviens qu'en 2013 l'ADEME vous étiez
probablement directrice de cabinet de la
ministre de l'écologie à l'époque madame
le Premier ministre à l'époque la dame
expliquait qu'en 2050 nous aurions
besoin de deux fois moins d'électricité
qu'aujourd'hui deux fois moins
d'électricité en 2050 quel aberration
comment déjà aussi sérieux ont-ils pu
écrire des choses aussi stupides voilà
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous nous annoncez
évidemment le tout électrique pour 2035
tout ça ne tient pas la route donc on
aurait aimé commencer par un débat
sérieux sur les besoins d'énergie de
notre pays le deuxième sujet c'est
évidemment d'avoir le courage à un
moment ou un autre d'un bras de fer avec
la Commission européenne
je devrais faire il sera nécessaire
depuis des années la Commission
européenne s'en prend à la situation
d'EDF à notre monopole EDF est un
champion national c'est une spécificité
EDF est la seule entreprise sans
équivalent en Europe sans équivalent
dans le monde à gérer un parc nucléaire
nous n'avons pas à accepter les demandes
de la Commission européenne la
Commission européenne doit aujourd'hui
faire se constat que tous les choix
qu'elle a fait faire à la France que
tout ce qu'elle a essayé de nous imposer
est un échec à commencer par la reine
qui était à l'époque un pisalet qui
était à l'époque un piset pour éviter le
démembrement la reine aujourd'hui est
une solution qui a été un échec total
puisque les fournisseurs alternatifs
mais on a le droit de le reconnaître on
a le droit d'être honnête ça arrive en
politique voilà et donc la reine la
reine était à l'époque un pigealet pour
éviter le démembrement d'EDF
c'était un pisalet parce que nous
voulions pas du démembrement d'EDF nous
mais aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître que
les autres que les opérateurs
alternatifs les fournisseurs alternatifs
n'ont pas tenu leurs engagements et non
pas investi en tout cas pour pour le
plus grand nombre
il faudra donc défendre cette intégrité
d'EDF je me réjouis que le combat de
notre collègue Marie-Noëlle baptistel
trouve enfin un écho favorable sur
l'hydroélectricité enfin sur la relance
du nucléaire madame le Premier ministre
le vrai sujet c'est celui de la durée de
vie de nos centrales et là encore
n'attendons pas d'être six mois avant
l'échéance pour ouvrir ce débat oui il
faudra aller au-delà des 50 ans oui il
faudra sans doute prolonger à 60 ans la
durée de vie de nos centrales nucléaires
pour faire la jonction avec le futur
programme EPR si vous le lancez si le
président de la République ne change pas
une nouvelle fois d'avis sur le sujet
alors bien sûr il faut des renouvelables
mais pas du tout éolien pas du tout
photovoltaïque vous n'avez aucune
ambition en matière de géothermie vous
n'avez qui pourrait être utilisé pour
des réseaux de chaleur urbain aucune
ambition dans votre texte vous n'avez
aucune ambition sur le méthanisation
aucune ambition en matière
hydro-électricité et de petites
hydroélectricité la France madame le
Premier ministre mérite mieux que de
dérouler des éoliennes allemandes ou
une photovoltaïque chinois merci
beaucoup monsieur le président
la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe bolo pour le
groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre messieurs les ministres madame
la ministre chers collègue
omniprésente abondante et accessible
l'énergie est accélérée nos déplacements
elle a amélioré notre confort et notre
santé et la sécurisé notre alimentation
elle a augmenté la productivité de notre
économie elle a facilité nos
communications à la diversifié nos
loisirs orchestrant et simplifiant notre
quotidien l'énergie abondante est bon
marché a construit notre addictions une
addiction aujourd'hui contestée par un
impératif climatique par une crise
sanitaire par une guerre aux portes de
l'Europe et par une capacité de
production dégradée et dépendante
d'importation
d'une consommation systématique et
machinale l'énergie est devenue un sujet
central de questionnement à quel prix
devons-nous la payer étant sûr d'avoir
assez d'énergie cet hiver
à une autre échelle elle est devenue une
arme de guerre un enjeu géopolitique de
nature à déterminer l'indépendance et la
souveraineté des nations et de tout un
continent dans un tel contexte l'énergie
devient une question de politique
nationale prioritaire notre assemblée
débat aujourd'hui de ce sujet majeur
pour lequel le groupe démocrate a une
vision à faire valoir
la politique énergique de énergétique de
la France
doit en premier lieu adresser les bonnes
réponses à quatre grands enjeux du mix
énergétique le premier enjeu c'est celui
de la décarbonation du mix énergétique
comme réponse impérative à une dérive
climatique qui ne peut plus être née et
dont les effets dévastateurs deviennent
chaque jour de plus en plus perceptibles
le deuxième enjeu c'est celui de la
trajectoire d'une électrification
massive des usages de l'énergie la
substitution des énergies fossiles
additionnées à la croissance économique
et démographique de la France va se
traduire par une envolée de notre
consommation les chiffres en apportent
la preuve notre consommation
d'électricité qui s'établit actuellement
à 400 toh atteindra 645 terawater à
l'horizon 2050 le troisième enjeu c'est
celui de la sécurisation des
approvisionnements durant les périodes
de fortes consommation comme moi vous
pouvez le mesurer chaque jour au travers
des sollicitations qui vous sont
adressées les questionnements et les
conséquences des possibles qui pourrait
intervenir cet hiver questionne nombre
de nos circonscitoyens et de nos
entreprises il est aujourd'hui
indispensable de retrouver des moyens de
production qui garantissent la
couverture de nos besoins le quatrième
enjeu c'est celui de la souveraineté
énergétique de la France alors que nous
entrons dans une époque où d'autres
crises conjoncturelles ne manqueront pas
de ce produit nous mesurons
collectivement combien la crise
énergétique européenne conséquence de la
guerre en Ukraine a mis en évidence
notre dépendance vis-à-vis des
importations d'énergie et la
vulnérabilité qui est la nôtre qui est
celle de nos sociétés lorsque ces
livraisons sont interrompues
en réponse à ces enjeux le groupe
démocrate appelle un mix énergétique
équilibrant le recours aux énergies
renouvelables avec la relance du parc
electronucléaire nous soutenons un mix
énergétique qui n'oublie pas le gaz la
trajectoire d'électrification ne fera
pas disparaître certains usages et nous
ne pouvons plus dépendre d'importation
coûteuse et aléatoire notre politique
énergétique doit porter l'ambition d'une
production de gaz vert en quantité
suffisante pour couvrir nos besoins les
scénarios de l'ADEME ceux de GrDF et de
nagawatt démontre que cette objective
est possible nous soutenons également un
mix énergétique qui s'appuie sur nos
territoires les territoires ruraux ont
en effet un rôle à jouer dans la
production d'électricité et de gaz dans
une relation renouvelée avec les
territoires urbains s'agissant toujours
des territoires et de la politique
énergétique de la France il nous semble
important de souligner que cette
politique doit apporter les réponses
attendues par les zones non
interconnectées de nos outre-mer
celle de contraintes géographique où la
production d'énergie est plus coûteuse
et contraignante qu'il s'agisse des
territoires ruraux ou des zones non
interconnectées dans les deux cas la
politique énergétique doit également
considérer le sujet du partage de la
valeur
nous demandons aussi un mix énergétique
en capacité de concilier le
développement de nouvelles capacités de
production
notamment renouvelables tout en
respectant la préservation des milieux
la biodiversité et les paysages nous
appelons enfin un mix énergétique qui
n'oublie pas le réseau ni la fiscalité
des énergies
s'agissant du réseau pourquoi en parler
parce qu'il n'y a pas de politique
énergétique qui puisse se résumer à la
production à la consommation
d'électricité et de gaz le réseau est
essentiel de ne pas être oublié en
particulier lorsqu'il est l'un des
moyens pour atteindre les objectifs de
la transition énergétique je fais ici
référence notamment à la capacité du
réseau électrique à accueillir les
infrastructures de recharge des
véhicules électriques ou à l'injection
diffuse des énergies renouvelables
électriques s'agissant de la fiscalité
de l'énergie elle aussi va devoir être
évoluée et être réformé un nouveau
modèle fiscal est souhaitable et
nécessaire il est indispensable en
réponse aux évolutions des consommations
et des usages dans une perspective de
maintien des recettes fiscales
au-delà d'un mix énergétique à même de
répondre à plusieurs défis la politique
énergétique de la France doit permettre
une sobriété indispensable à l'enjeu
climatique et à celui de l'efficience
des usages de nos consommations le
groupe démocrate appelle une sobriété
solidaire pour permettre aux ménage les
plus modestes de prendre leur part aux
adaptations que chaque Français va
devoir mener une sobriété de bon sens
porteuse d'économies pour celles et ceux
qui la pratiquent une sobriété qui
s'adresse pas uniquement à ceux qui ont
les moyens de rénover leur logement de
changer leur véhicule d'adopter des
modes d'adopter des modes de vie et de
consommation moins énergivores si les
dispositifs ma prime rénov et
d'acquisition de véhicules propres vont
dans le bon sens ils peuvent faire
l'objet d'amélioration s'agissant de la
prime rénove les chiffres témoignent
d'une forte mobilisation des ménages et
d'un ciblage qui bénéficie effectivement
au ménage des plus modestes notre groupe
appelle un gain supplémentaire au moyen
de critères d'éligibilité qui vise à
davantage déficience de l'argent public
les euros investis à la fois maximiser
les économies de kilowatt-heure et
minimiser les émissions de CO2
s'agissant s'agissant excusez-moi des
aides à la mobilité les dispositifs
d'accompagnement et d'incitation doivent
tenir compte des spécificités des
territoires ruraux et de la nécessité
pour de nombreux de leurs habitants
d'utiliser quotidiennement leur véhicule
personnel et individuels pour des
déplacements professionnels pour déposer
les enfants à l'école pour aller faire
leur course pour se rendre chez leur
médecin la démonstration est ainsi faite
qu'une politique énergétique doit être
globale et intégrer les dimensions
sectorielles du logement des mobilités
du commerce de l'accès à la santé pour
terminer le groupe démocrate appel à une
politique qui garantissent la fourniture
d'une énergie à des prix accessibles à
tous cette ambition trouve des réponses
à l'échelle européenne en effet il
semble aujourd'hui évident que certaines
règles du marché européen de l'énergie
empêche les mesures nécessaires pour
contenir l'envolée du prix des prix du
gaz et l'électricité c'est envolé des
prix qui paralyse le tissu économique
qui gèle le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
qui alourdit les charges des
collectivités et qui fait douter les
associations de capacité à poursuivre
leur mission
les réponses budgétaires débutent
réponse budgétaires ne peuvent devenir
la norme
[Musique]
face au risque d’enlisement dans la
crise et face aux prochaines crises qui
ne manqueront pas d'arriver le réflexe
budgétaire présente en effet le danger
d'alourdir considérablement et
durablement notre dette si le bouclier
tarifaire si la minoration nathaic s'est
fait ticfe excusez-moi si les différents
chèques énergie si l'amortisseur
électrique si le fond vert ou encore la
réduction du prix des carburants à la
pompe ont été démesures pertinentes et
utiles d'autres leviers doivent être
actionnés à l'échelon européen c'est
leviers continentaux c'est évidemment la
désindexation du prix de l'électricité
sur celui du gaz c'est également les
évolutions indispensables et nécessaires
à négocier en lien avec la fin des TRV
et de la reine notre groupe soutient des
dispositions de nature à valoriser les
atouts de la France au bénéfice des
Français qui financent depuis des
décennies les outils de production d'EDF
et les réseaux qui nous acheminent ces
énergies auxquelles nous sommes
profondément accoutumés
en conclusion et pour résumer la
position du groupe démocrate nous
attendons une politique de l'énergie qui
conjugue décarbonation avec sobriété
acceptée une politique énergique
énergétique qui permette un prix des
énergies accessibles aux ménage les plus
modestes dans tous les usages qu'ils
soient domestiques ou de mobilité une
politique de l'énergie qui garantissent
l'indépendance et la souveraineté de la
France je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Dominique potier pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames madame et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues le groupe
socialiste prend la parole dans ce débat
avec une certaine humidité au vu du
vertige des décisions qui sont devant
nous le fait qu'une certaine humidité au
vu du cri de la terre et du cri des
pauvres c'est pauvres qui cet hiver
devront arbitrer entre se chauffer et se
nourrir et ces millions de personnes qui
parlent de le monde subiront les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
et du dérèglement économique qui
provoque déjà des famines nous le
faisons avec l'état d'esprit de 8
milliards d'êtres humains qui devront
apprendre à vivre ensemble et donc à
partager et au-delà toutes les
révolutions technologiques scientifiques
qui seront évoquées ici c'est bien cette
révolution fraternelle celle du partage
qui est le plus grand défi qu'un autre
humanité aujourd'hui en effet si nous
devons tous collectivement passer de
neuf à deux tonnes de carbone par
habitant des missions de carbone chacun
nous savons que pour les plus riches
d'entre nous c'est 20 tonnes pour les
plus pauvres 4 tonnes dans des pays
comme les nôtres mais que pour tous
l'effort de décarbonation va être
abyssale va être une véritable
révolution un choc de civilisation c'est
une question de vie de et de mort pour
notre humanité au sens du terme c'est
également et nous l'avons réappris
à cause et dans le cadre de la crise
ukrainienne c'est une question de
démocratie ou de sens du terme notre
capacité à vivre l'égalité et la
solidarité au sein d'une nation mais
également la capacité d'une nation à
affirmer son autonomie sa souveraineté
populaire l'essence même de la
démocratie dans le concert des nations
bref à s'affranchir des servitudes
qu'elles soient celles du gaz russe ou
du pétrole qui n'est pas toujours
produit nous le savons dans des espaces
de grandes démocratie et où sont
respectées les droits humains bref c'est
sortir d'une servitude à une certaine
forme de progrès également affirmer
notre volonté de liberté pour participer
au récits du monde nous le faisons avec
la conscience que nous sommes dans
l'urgence et que pourtant et c'est toute
la difficulté il nous faut penser le
temps long toujours penser le temps long
nous le faisons d'autant plus que nous
sortons de deux décennies de décennies
où nous avons en partie perdu du temps
car nous n'avons mis en place ni la
sobriété au bon niveau ni le choix d'un
rarement nucléaire ni celui du
déplacement du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables il y a eu des pas il y a
eu des hésitations et il y a eu une
prise de conscience qui désormais domine
nos sociétés et le monde et fait
quasiment consensus quand on bute à
atteindre mais il n'y a pas eu les
efforts nécessaires puisque nous
constatons aujourd'hui dans un effort de
vérité que nous avons encore 65% de
l'énergie finale consommée qui est
d'origine fossile et seulement 19% de NR
dans la fabrique de l'énergie dans notre
pays donc deux décennies en partie
perdue avec des mécanismes comme la
reine dans la loi l'homme de
2010 qui affaiblit la puissance publique
sans tenir la promesse pour les
opérateurs alternatifs de la réalisation
du mix énergétique il nous faut réparer
cela avec des tarifs réglementés pour la
vente aux citoyens aux collectivités et
aux entreprises c'est la proposition que
porte les socialistes dans la sortie de
la reine et nous devons en finir au
chapitre des réparations avec cette tout
ce dont souligné en
le prix du gaz et de l'électricité en
sortant de cette Absurdie européenne
dont nous devons sortir rapidement
l'enjeu je l'ai dit pour les socialistes
et nous l'espérons pour une majorité ici
c'est la décarbonation c'est l'urgence
aujourd'hui et c'est d'urgence demain
c'est l'urgence du temps long des
carbonés c'est penser planète on la peut
dit jusqu'à présent à cette dans cette
hémicycle ces pensées planètes et madame
la Première ministre j'ai trois
questions à vous poser sur la sur les
questions internationales
lundi la France devra se prononcer sur
le traité de la charte de l'énergie le
président de la République a annoncé la
volonté de la France dans Sortir or il y
a une essaie de modernisation du TCE à
l'échelle européenne l'Allemagne s'est
prononcée d'autres pays pouvaient vous
nous affirmer que la France au minimum
s'abstiendra au minimum s'abîmera pour
cette modernisation du TCE qui
poursuivrait son œuvre mortifère dans la
garantie donnée aux acteurs privés des
énergies fossiles deuxième enjeu un
règlement deuxième enjeu c'est un
règlement européen qui va prévoir pour
le retrait carbone pour les
compensations carbone des dispositions à
l'échelle internationale pouvez-vous
nous garantir et vous engager madame la
Première ministre à ce que la France
milite comme le font les députés
socialistes européens aujourd'hui pour
qu'un aucun cas ces compensations
carbone à l'autre bout du monde
deviennent accaparés des terres qui
servent à qui sont au service de la
sécurité alimentaire collective et
notamment de la souveraineté de peuples
paysans nous ne pourrons pas planter des
forêts pour pour payer sous forme
d'indulgence notre mode de vie au
détriment des sécurités collectives dans
un monde interdépendant et au nom des
valeurs qui nous rassemblent enfin alors
que Total et d'autres opérateurs gaziers
ou du pétrole engage en Afrique et au
Qatar des plans d'investissement
important je pense notamment au plan de
l'Ouganda je vous dire madame la
Première ministre que nous sommes
choqués nous l'avons dit mille fois de
l'indécence de Total dans le refus et
dans votre refus d'engager un partage
des profits et des supers profits et des
profits qui ont été faits à l'occasion
de cette guerre et je voudrais vous dire
aussi que une autre histoire que celle
de Total en Ouganda pourrait s'écrire
l'Afrique recèle des réserves
extraordinaires par le vent par le
soleil par leurs ressources cinétique de
ces fleuves l'Afrique est une ressource
inépuisable de production d'énergie
renouvelables alors nous rêvons que nos
entreprises
nationale que notre savoir-faire
industriel notre richesse notre
recherche l'Agence française de
développement investissent aux côtés des
États africains investissent dans une
logique de co-développement pour
produire cette énergie électrifiée pour
échanger l'énergie cette énergie verte
c'est l'aventure que la génération
climat demande à notre pays et non pas
ses investissements du passé du passé
dont nous savons les conséquences
néfastes pour les droits humains et pour
l'écologie décarboner ces pensées
planètes c'est également penser
puissance publique celle des territoires
que nous voulons mettre au centre de la
décision et du partage de valeurs dans
les énergies renouvelables celles de
l'État qui seul peut planifier au long
cours peut garantir le partage de la
valeur et les péréquations cet état il a
un nom c'est l'opérateur de l'entreprise
publique EDF comme la République madame
la Première ministre EDF l'entreprise
publique et une et indivisible
garantissez nous qu'il n'y aura pas de
démantèlement enfin notre horizon
et celui et celui de l'Europe il est
mille fois celui de l'Europe mille fois
celui de l'Europe celui d'une Europe qui
organise les marchés de l'énergie qui se
projettent dans des coopérations avec
l'Afrique d'une Europe qui partage qui
invente qui recherche et qui engage la
décarbonation à un rythme au-delà de ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui encore avec le
green DIN nous avons aujourd'hui des
besoins d'un Schuman comme à une époque
organisé le marché de l'acier et du
charbon qui invente celle des énergies
vertes et de la sobriété du futur nous
avons besoin de cette Europe là nous
avons besoin d'une oeuvre d'Europe
souveraine puissante et solidaire enfin
nous le savons décarbonés c'est engagé
la sobriété notre groupe délété a
produit un travail à produit une
centaine de propositions pratiques très
concrètes que je ne vais pas déployer
ici mais simplement vous dire qu'elle
touche à la fois un art de vivre cet art
de vivre ce n'est pas forcément la
tristesse ou la rétractation ça peut
être la découverte d'autres
compartiments de l'existence mais c'est
également une aventures économiques
alors que dans les années 70 nous
consacrions 4% du PIB à l'investissement
structurel dans les infrastructures nous
en sommes à 2% aujourd'hui avec 1% de
plus nous pouvons relever les défis
suivants celui du bâtiment ou notre
groupe depuis 5 ans propose un plan
financé vérifié avec la Caisse des
Dépôts consignations qui fonctionnent
qui a été validée avec la Fédération des
bâtiments et qui permet d'engager à
l'horizon 2050 la la bâtiments passifs
pour 26 millions de logements dans notre
pays notre plan c'est l'agriculture avec
un tiers des engrais azotés qui est
valent les engrasser qui représentent un
tiers de ces consommations d'énergie
l'agroécologie et l'innovation
technologique et scientifique dans
l'agroécologie permet de s'affranchir de
cette dépendance aux engrais azotés et
aux consommations glacières notamment
russes qu'il suppose c'est dans la
mobilité les trois milliards que
demandés l'ensemble des présidents des
présidents de région pour engager les
transports en commun mais c'est
également un milliard qui serait
nécessaire à VNF pour que le domaine
public fluvial devienne à énergie
positive notre sobriété c'est
l'innovation c'est sortir de la vieille
croissance pour engager une nouvelle
prospérité nous devons changer de monde
nous devons décarboner nous devons
choisir la part des ENR nous savons les
forces et les fragilités de ce NRS
notamment au niveau des stockages même
si nous ne sommes pas technologies
finies et que nous savons que notamment
dans le maritime dans dans les capacités
de des hydroliennes des forces ou le
motrices nous avons et dans la
géothermie des ressources
extraordinaires mais nous savons les
difficultés de stockage et l'hydrogène
reste encore une promesse qu'il faut
conforter nous savons pour le nucléaire
la question du temps et du coup des
savoir-faire conquis dans notre pays
nous savons également les dépendances en
amont 70% de l'Europe plus de 50% de
l’uranium passe par la Russie
réfléchissons à ne pas engager pour le
siècle qui vient une nouvelle servitude
et nous savons qu'en aval la question du
stockage irréversible pose une question
anthropologique alors nous serons en
rendez-vous nous serons au rendez-vous
du mais de vous faire un processus
démocratique et scientifique qui passe à
notre sens par une inversion du
calendrier nous devons faire la SNBC et
le débat sur la PPE avant de trancher la
question du nucléaire nous prendrons nos
responsabilités mais dans ce chemin
démocratique qui passe à notre sens par
un grand débat organisé avec le Conseil
national du débat public nous devons à
la fois pour des raisons d'efficacité et
pour des raisons déficiences de la
science de la démocratie nous serons
rendez vous c'est une grande aventure
industrielle d'aménagement du territoire
et de démocratie qui nous attend nous
serons au rendez-vous
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Henri alfonsdari pour le groupe
horizon et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues des
premiers savants prédisant un
dérèglement climatique que beaucoup
qualifièrent de fou pour ne pas avoir à
s'inquiéter des conséquences de leur
choix depuis il y a eu nombre d'études
scientifiques de rapports de discours
des missions de télévision de
documentaires de films de déclaration à
l'emporte-pièce et aussi de propos
éclairés et productif
nous avons presque tout entendu le
constat est clair le réchauffement
climatique est un contestable en tant
qu'humanité il nous est difficile de
comprendre que nous ne pouvons plus
attendre pour agir
si nous nous accordons sur le fait que
ce sont les activités humaines qui sont
à la source de se réchauffement alors
nous devons nous rejoindre aussi sur le
fait que c'est avant tout les ressources
utiles à nos systèmes qui en sont les
variables et en premier lieu c'est
nécessaire à la production d'énergie
à vrai dire quelle que soit le système
capitaliste ou collectiviste pas un seul
ensemble politique du 20e et 21e siècle
n'a pu se passer des ressources
énergétiques pour faire vivre les aides
dont il avait la responsabilité
ces ressources énergétiques nécessaires
au progrès socle du contrat social ou de
la paix sociale sont qualifiés par
certains d'esclaves énergétiques notre
progrès social ou économique notre
richesse se font donc sur une ressource
que nous ne payons pas sa juste valeur
et qui plus est dont l'utilisation est
néfaste à l'évolution de notre climat et
à l'avenir de l'humanité
à cet instant je comprendrais
parfaitement que vous disiez que nous
dirigions vers un avenir sombre et
inquiétant obamo catastrophique que vous
décidiez de ne pas entendre un Cassandre
de plus et de profiter au plus tôt du
temps qu'il vous reste
justement du temps il nous en reste pas
longtemps 20 ans
si nous émettons l'énergie pas la
fossile mais la plus renouvelable est
décarbonée qui soit c'est à dire notre
volonté nous pouvons travailler dès
aujourd'hui à sortir des énergies
fossiles de choisir d'arrêter de gâcher
d'innover pour montrer l'exemple
d'échanger pour entraîner le monde et
l'humanité dans un avenir vivable et
désirable ceci nous le ferons en
redonnant à la France et aux Français
confiance en eux-mêmes confiance en leur
talent en leur travail en leur choix et
dans leur avenir nous devons agir sur la
première des variables du changement
climatique l'énergie nous devons
produire plus d'électricité des carbonée
et nous passer définitivement des
énergies fossiles c'est une perspective
et pour atteindre une perspective il
faut une stratégie cette stratégie
explique dès aujourd'hui grâce au
président de la République aux
précédents gouvernement et à celui-ci
dont la stratégie nationale bas carbone
et la stratégie de neutralité carbone
européenne c'est l'objectif minimal que
chacun sur ses bancs doit garder à
l'esprit
pour penser l'avenir il faut le
connaître son passé et en termes de
stratégie énergétique la France a un
passé riche plein d'enseignements pour
ce que nous devons réaliser ici et
demain ces mots de Jacques Chirac
prononcés à la Sorbonne précise la
nature de la planification à la
française la planification française et
c'est là son originalité n'est pas né
d'un esprit de système organiser ce qui
doit l'être sans renoncer à la libre
entreprise et à la liberté des échanges
dès l'origine notre plan est placé sous
le signe du pragmatisme il fallait que
l'État a eu les moyens d'imposer au
conservatisme renaissant l'impérius
nécessité de la reconstruction et de la
modernisation c'est pour cela que fut
crée le Commissariat général aux plans
qui est reçu pour mission de fixer les
priorités de mobiliser les moyens et
d'accroître la productivité de
l'économie française
puis les années 60 ou le général de
Gaulle a soit l'indépendance stratégique
de notre armée en développant le
nucléaire militaire ouvrant ainsi la
voie au programme de nucléaire civils en
1973 de ce pétrolier qui décide à Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing a lancé la
construction de 13 réacteurs entre 74 et
75 ces réacteurs et ceux qui les ont
suivis contribuèrent jusqu'ici à défaut
d'une verre interable indépendance
énergétique à notre souveraineté et un
vrai confort d'approvisionnement arrivé
au pouvoir François Mitterrand plutôt
que de défaire s'inscrivit dans les pas
de ses prédécesseurs
il y a aussi des détours et des échecs
l'arrêt et le démantèlement de super
Phénix l'abandon du projet Astrid et la
lenteur du déploiement des ENR
la reine dispositif daté qui a largement
participé à l'affaiblissement de notre
opérateur historique et abattu en brèche
la cohérence de la stratégie énergétique
française au regard des directions
prises par nos partenaires européens
heureusement il prendra fin en 2025 mais
nous devons rester vigilants sur
l'évolution des règles européennes à
l'heure où je vous parle nous n'avons
pas atteint nos objectifs en matière de
transition écologique et énergétique
pour ce faire nous avons besoin de
levier d'action en premier lieu il nous
fait un vrai marché des crédits carbone
donner un prix au carbone et l'outil
d'une transition écologique juste et
efficace qui garantissent un aussi
citoyen et à nos entreprises une énergie
propre et bon marché une adaptation
accélérée de notre économie et notre
agriculture un financement de service
public des cartes données notamment une
mobilité facteur d'équité territoriales
et générateur de biodiversité par le
besoin de séquestration constant
de la transition dans la ligne du
Commissariat au Plan le marché du crédit
carbone est un levier qui ne consacre
pas le triomphe du dirigisme sur
l'économie de marché
il y a aussi tous ces petits sujets qui
sont pourtant majeurs et sur lesquels
nous pouvons agir dès maintenant la
production de la biodiversité la
protection de la biodiversité des
ressources la préservation de la qualité
de l'eau des paysages la conservation de
nos terres agricoles et le développement
des circuits courts la lutte contre la
pollution notamment celle des plastiques
et finalement tout ce qui touche à la
consommation notamment ce que celle qui
est superflu et nous nous pourrions nous
passer sans aucune atteinte à nos modes
de vie puis la question opérationnelle
qui devrait être au coeur des débats
faute de quoi nous qu'on le risque d'en
rester indéfiniment en pétition de
principe nous devons pallier enfin à ce
qui nous a manqué la capacité de tenir
nos décisions un état qui donne des
zones objectifs fermes tout en
s'appuyant sur les territoires leurs
élus et leurs administrés pour qu'ils
s'approprient et déploie ses stratégies
sur le terrain au bénéfice de leurs
habitants de notre souveraineté et de la
résilience de notre modèle
un modèle c'est ce nom la France a
besoin et ce que nous devons bâtir un
modèle utile à nos concitoyens mais
aussi à nos partenaires européens sans
oublier les pays en développement qui
aspirent au progrès et pour qui ce
modèle doit être source d'inspiration
n'oublions pas nos amis allemands nous
devons trouver les moyens de les faire
profiter de la robustesse du futur mix
énergétique français un mix décarboné
s'appuyant à la fois sur le nucléaire et
le renouvelable qui donnera demain à
toute l'Europe ce qui était hier le seul
avantage compétitif de la France
mes chers amis amis car dans notre
devise il y a la fraternité c'est cette
fraternité que nous devons avoir les uns
envers les autres c'est à dire la
responsabilité que nous avons bâtir ou
de conserver un contrat social où chacun
trouve sa place et son rôle dans cette
odyssée qui est l'adaptation au
changement climatique au-delà de
l'effroi et de la sidération face à
cette situation de crise qui se dessine
et nous imprime nous devons par l'unité
le choix de l'intérêt général tracer une
ligne claire sur le monde que nous
voulons bâtir demain ça commence dès
aujourd'hui avec ce débat avec deux lois
d'accélération ENR et nucléaire qui sont
les deux phases d'une même pièce et avec
la PPE qui fixera nos ambitions pour les
prochaines années si importantes pour le
siècle à venir
le groupe horizon pense que dans cet
assemblée qui représente la diversité de
nos pays nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas que nous sachions que
nous sachions nous hisser tous ensemble
à la hauteur des attentes qu'il place en
nous quant à la conduite de leur avenir
je vous remercie
la parole et maintenant à Monsieur
Charles Fournier pour le groupe
écologiste pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues pendant
l'entre-deux entre deux tours de la
présidentielle le président de la
République avait annoncé un quinquennat
qui serait écologique ou ne sera pas le
sens de la formule il nous a habitué au
bon mot pour mener ce combat du siècle
comme il l'a défini un pilote a été
désigné c'est vous madame la Première
ministre des stratégies ont été fixées
et des changements radicaux programmés
pour agir sur tous les fronts la
métaphore guerrière chère au langage du
président est assumé mais la
planification écologique et énergétique
elle n'est toujours pas identifiée
est-ce le signe d'une prise de
conscience et d'une volonté d'agir vite
et de manière cohérente en fait nous
avons plus le sentiment d'une
procrastination écologique il aura fallu
attendre 6 mois depuis des annonces
promette et de graves épisode de
canicule et de sécheresse pour que
madame la Première ministre lance enfin
le 21 octobre un outil à vocation
planificatrice le plan France nation
verte mais de quelle planification
parlons-nous d'une volonté d'agir étape
par étape filière par filière territoire
par territoire pour atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques et de protection
de la biodiversité c'est insistance à
segmenter le calendrier les acteurs et
les concertations nous font craindre la
politique des petits pas écologiques et
de l'incohérence dans ce contexte la
politique énergétique actuelle de la
France apparaît problématique à
plusieurs égards d'abord l'irruption de
la sobriété dans le langage
gouvernemental après avoir été fustigé
pendant tant d'années mais une sobriété
vu comme la somme des efforts des uns et
des autres sans changement structurels
sans amorcer un changement de modèle
ensuite la France n'est pas un bon élève
en matière de développement d'énergie
renouvelable c'est le dernier pays
d'Europe à ne pas tenir ses objectifs si
nous les avions tenus nous aurions de
disponible six fois l'équivalent de
Fessenheim aujourd'hui et nous
n'aborderions pas la période hivernale
avec la même difficulté c'est aussi une
ambition revue à la baisse sur le budget
carbone
2019-2023 de notre pays et un grave
manque de cohérence on nous annonce à
sortie de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles dans le cadre de la loi pouvoir
d'achat et pourtant on rouvre
possiblement une centrale à charbon on
crée un terminal métier pour importer du
gaz de schiste américain et nous sommes
complaisants face aux grands pollueurs
et leurs bombes climatiques je vous ai
posé une question lors des questions au
gouvernement et je n'ai pas eu de
réponse ensuite un calendrier découpé on
nous annonce d'un côté un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables puis un projet de
loi visant accélérer la construction des
installations nucléaires puis une loi de
programmation énergie climat une
inversion qui laisse à penser que les
choix sont déjà fait et enfin un
problème de méthode le président avait
parlé d'un grand débat sur le mix
énergétique sur le futur énergétique de
la France à cet instant pas de débat pas
d'annonces sur ce débat et donc pour les
Français le brouillard comment
voulez-vous que nos concitoyens
comprennent les choix politiques
énergétiques et yader face à
l'incertitude sur l'approvisionnement
les tensions sur les prix les co-anxiété
les Français ont besoin d'une ambition
politique au plus haut niveau d'un cadre
simple et lisible pour fixer des
objectifs à moyen et long terme et d'une
mobilisation collective de tous les
acteurs de la société c'est ça la
planification depuis longtemps les
écologistes ne disent la transition
énergétique repose sur trois piliers la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique et les
énergies renouvelables la sobriété ce
n'est pas une punition et elle doit être
pensée dans la justice sociale
l'efficacité énergétique nous vous avons
fait des propositions 12 milliards pour
réussir la rénovation thermique de
l'habitat face au balbutiements de ma
prime rénov vous ne l'avez refusé enfin
la transition énergétique doit reposer
sur les énergies renouvelables le projet
de loi énergie renouvelable peut être
l'occasion de revoir à la hausse nos
ambitions sur le sujet la balle est dans
votre camp pour en faire un véritable
outil d'accélération qui respecte le
code de l'environnement la biodiversité
et le débat public mais parce que l'on
ne change pas le monde sans les gens il
est tout aussi urgent d'imaginer comment
nos concitoyens et concitoyens peuvent
s'approprier ces enjeux et y être
associés je vous donne un exemple dans
ma circonscription la ville de Tours et
la métropole de tours on vient de nous
mettre en place un Conseil de sobriété
voilà type de démarche qui peuvent
inspirer cette ce chemin démocratique il
nous faut construire car la question est
sérieusement à cet endroit vous parlez
d'un grand débat mais lequel pour quel
résultat allez vous suivre les
recommandations de la CNDP comment
envisagez-vous d'associer les jeunes
générations à ses choix comment le
seront aussi les collectivités les
entreprises les ONG les chercheurs mais
aussi les acteurs de la culture et du
sport c'est non seulement un enjeu de
méthode mais aussi d'éthique et de
confiance dans l'avenir les bons mots ne
suffisent plus l'heure est à la
bifurcation écologique et à la cohérence
de l'action publique c'est ce que nous
devons aux générations futures le seul
antilope du désespoir c'est l'action
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur max mathiasin pour
le groupe liotte pour 5 minutes
également
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Michel collègue la nouvelle
méthode promise par le gouvernement se
fait toujours un peu attendre on nous
avait parlé de co-construction nous
constatons que les décisions vont vite
ne sont opposés sur d'autres mix
énergétique sur le nucléaire sur EDF on
nous parle d'économie d'énergie mais les
Français ont-ils d'autres choix que de
réduire leur consommation face à la
flambée des prix et les obligations
semblent peser toujours sur les mêmes
dépend entier de notre économie en
revanche le s'inscrivent pas dans cette
démarche de sobriété énergétique le
secteur du numérique par exemple ne
semble pas soumis aux mêmes contraintes
et je ne suis pas certain que le
gouvernement allait pris toute la mesure
alors dans les prochains jours nous
aurons examiné le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production une
énergie renouvelable nos collègues
sénateurs l'ont déjà considérablement
riches puisqu'il a été multiplié un
volume bien sûr par 4 ce projet de loi
qui concerne non seulement notre avenir
énergie énergétique mais également
environnemental aurait mérité quelques
jours supplémentaires afin de consulter
plus largement les représentants des
énergies renouvelables les élus des
territoires les scientifiques afin
d'intégrer de manière cohérente toute ou
la plupart de leur propositions quand il
est bien évident qu'à côté du nucléaire
existant partiellement à l'arrêt et du
nucléaire un projet à l'horizon lointain
notre richesse sur les énergies
renouvelables de nos territoires à
partir de ressources de nos territoires
pour atteindre l'objectif de l'autonomie
énergétique la politique énergétique de
la France semble de la France a beau se
décider au niveau national et doit être
décliné au niveau local le mix
énergétique doit être mis en œuvre de
façon différenciée territoire ba
territoire avec les atouts et les
contraintes de chacun et en particulier
dans les fameuses zones non
interconnectées que sont principalement
les outre-mer et la Corse de nos
outre-mer l'essentiel de l'électricité
est produit à partir de fioul et de
charbon importé qui font des milliers de
kilomètres avant d'atteindre nos côtes
quel bilan carbone alors que nous avons
sur place des richesses inépuisables et
je ne pense pas qu'au solaire je pense
aussi surtout pour la Guadeloupe à la
géothermie qui est la plus formidable
source d'énergie renouvelable décarbonée
inépuisable 24
sur 24 indépendante de la météo contre
mon solaire ou à l'éolien en plus la
géothermie permet de fabriquer le livre
de l'hydrogène vert sans émission de gaz
à effet de serre nous recevions réunion
en audition ces derniers jours les
acteurs de l'énergie des scientifiques
de Guadeloupe qui soulignait que nous
avions sur notre archipel à Bouillante
la seule source de géothermie de France
à haute température c'est notre atout
principal mais si qui n'est aujourd'hui
que suffisamment exploité puisqu'il
n'est qu'à 20% de ses capacités et la
dynamique est toujours présente on a
découvert un nouveau réservoir de
géothermie qui semble la cour plus riche
que le premier le potentiel est donc
énorme et le modèle de bouillon peut
être
dupliquer dans les autres territoires
volcaniques français en Martinique par
exemple et à la Réunion mais il faut
pour cela accompagner nos industries et
dans leur entreprise de recherche de
forage aujourd'hui coûteuse et dont le
rendement était certes
nous disposons également dans les années
de possibilités d'exploiter l'énergie ou
le motrice de l'énergie de la mer
l'expérience sur le motrice a démontré
par exemple dans le sud dans le Nord
grandir sa réussite
il est impératif de donner davantage de
visibilité aux différents acteurs des
énergies renouvelables pour qu'ils
puissent investir former les salariés
anticiper les projets sur plusieurs
années cela passe en particulier par les
appels d'offres plus fréquents de la
creux
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
et pas une mutualisation des coûts cela
passe par également par une remise à
plat de la fiscalité locale en outre-mer
puisqu'une bonne partie des recettes des
collectivités provient de la taxe sur
les produits pétroliers importés il
faudra éviter les cueilles d'une
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
ambitieuse qui conduirait à une chute
des recettes des collectivités les
territoires
ultramarins ont la capacité d'atteindre
l'objectif de 40% d'énergie renouvelable
dans le mix énergétique en 2030 et même
de le dépasser très largement en
Guadeloupe par exemple la région affiche
39% d'énergie renouvelables dans le mix
électrique EDF signal qu'une électricité
à 100% renouvelable est possible d'ici
2030 avec la conversion au
biocombulsibles et tous les moyens
thermiques fossiles les ressources sont
là localement en particulier dans les
zones non interconnectées et ne demande
et ne demande qu'à être exploitée c'est
la solution pour atteindre l'autonomie
dans les outre-mer madame la ministre il
faut nous aider investir
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Maud Brejon pour le
groupe renaissance pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues je vous
propose de revenir quelques années en
arrière pour commencer octobre 1981
c'était il y a plus de 40 ans nos
prédécesseurs des batailles déjà dans
cette assemblée sur le programme
d'indépendance énergétique proposé par
le gouvernement d'alors climat
souveraineté pouvoir d'achat à la seule
différence du charbon perçue comme une
opportunité industrielle pour le pays
toutes les questions que le sont posées
tout comme les solutions que l'on
entrevoit était déjà sur la table il
était déjà question d'économie d'énergie
de développement du nucléaire et même
énergie renouvelables avec un objectif
de 150 térawatters dans le mix
énergétique en 1990 l'industrie non plus
n'était pas en reste
l'industrie non plus pardon n'était pas
oublié tout comme la politique
énergétique en matière d'agriculture par
l'utilisation de biocarburant par
exemple et de grandes ambitions en
matière d'innovation et de recherche
ce programme était ambitieux tout en
étant rationnel quand reste-t-il 16
novembre 2022 les énergies fossiles
représentent toujours plus de 60% de
l'énergie finale consommée en France et
85% dans le monde elle pèsent sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages elles ont pu
notre souveraineté énergétique et
impacte le climat la situation
d'aujourd'hui est assez similaire à
celle du débat de 1981 une crise
économique qui rappelle c'est que celle
des chocs pétroliers et une dépendance
aux énergies fossiles qui contraint nos
réponses politiques la majorité
construit sa politique énergétique sur
un principe clair et sans équivoque
faire en sorte que les mêmes causes ne
produisent pas les mêmes effets
alors cette politique quelle est elle
d'abord tout comme la stratégie dressée
par le président Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing à l'époque et poursuivi les
années durant elle trouve ses
fondamentaux dans la science et les
technologies alors où certains
politiques ont fait le choix des
croyances notons d'ailleurs que des
débat de 1981 ce risque de perdre
confiance en la science avait été pointé
ensuite une volonté farouche de ne
jamais opposer les énergies des
carbonées entre elles et je m'arrêterai
sur ce point là j'entends trop de prise
de parole venus de toutes parts dans
l'hémicycle opposés les énergies des
carbonées entre elles en oubliant de
parler des énergies fossiles 60% de
l'énergie finale consommée en France 85%
dans le monde et les renouvelables et
l'énergie nucléaire seront nécessaires
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
pour gagner notre souveraineté
énergétique et pour répondre à la
question du pouvoir d'achat
[Applaudissements]
commençons par les énergies
renouvelables dans des plaisent à une
partie de cet assemblée elles sont
incontournables si on veut maintenir un
mix électrique pardon des carbonés du
GIEC à R2 en passant par toutes les
associations même les plus favorables au
nucléaire toutes sont formelles
déploiement de production
photovoltaïques d'éolien sur terre
comment mère dans toutes les
trajectoires de décarbonation l'ensemble
des moyens de production bas carbone
sont nécessaires pour compléter la
production d'électricité qui devra
augmenter et à ceux qui vous diront
qu'elle coûte trop cher rappelez-leur
que fin 2023 les deux tiers des
subventions versées en 21 ans auront été
remboursés soit 43 milliards d'euros
c'est en fait depuis 2022 en raison de
la hausse des prix de l'électricité les
énergies le renouvelables ne coûtent
rien à l'état elle génère des recettes
qui servent aujourd'hui à limiter pour
nos concitoyens et nos entrepreneurs les
hausses de factures d'énergie
le nucléaire ensuite
un choix de courage et un programme
d'indépendance énergétique tel furent
les mots employés par Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing puis Pierre Mauroy pour
qualifier notre industrie nucléaire à
l'heure où les énergies fossiles je l'ai
déjà dit pèse 60 % de notre consommation
en France le nucléaire a épargné à la
planète 75 milliards de tonnes de CO2 et
éviter plus d'un million de décès du à
la pollution de l'air
à l'échelle nationale il produit environ
60% 70% de notre électricité alors si
certains pays voisins ont fait le choix
d'en sortir dans la droite clean
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et de la
France insoumise les impacts sont sans
appel l'Allemagne démarre de nouvelles
centrales à charbon essayez à la Russie
vient des apports massives de gaz en
Belgique de nouvelles centrales à gaz
fossiles sont prévues augmentant
significativement les émissions de CO2
jusqu'à en faire en 2030 le plus mauvais
élève de l'Union européenne en matière
de climat après la Pologne voilà vers
l'orientation vers laquelle vous
souhaitez nous mener
quant à l'uranium chers collègues les
fèves quantités importées discréditent
l'argument d'une dépendance à la
ressource d'autant que la France dispose
de réserves et de moyens de retraitement
rendant ainsi possible l'exploitation
dans centrale sans apport du moindre
minerai pendant 10 ans ce qui compte
c'est la maîtrise de la technologie et
la France est à ce titre l'un des rares
pays allait tenir cette expertise
mondialement reconnue que nous ne
serions par ailleurs laissés entre les
seuls mains de la Chine et de la Russie
pour terminer je voudrais avoir quelques
mots pour toutes celles et ceux qui font
ces industries chaudronniers mécanicien
électricien robinettiez chimiste
automaticien au taux de femmes porteurs
de compétences rares et qui font notre
fierté dont nous ne parlons pas
suffisamment et à qui nous devons
beaucoup je terminerai donc mon
intervention en ayant quelques mots pour
eux
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan pour 5 minutes également
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues grâce
à l'action visionnaire du général de
Gaulle et de Georges Pompidou la France
a disposé pendant des décennies d'une
électricité souveraine bon marché sur et
non polluant malheureusement leur
successeur soumis à l'Union européenne
ont accepté la libéralisation absurde du
marché de l'électricité et du gaz
gâchant l’inestimable à tout que
constituait EDF GDF pire encore
l'incompétence la démagogie
l'incohérence des gouvernements de
François Hollande et d'Emmanuel Macron
ont précipité l'économie française dans
une impasse énergétique et
environnementale
mes chers collègues qui a osé écrire le
27 novembre 2018 sur le nucléaire
concrètement 14 réacteurs seront fermés
d'ici 2035 ce mouvement commencera à
l'été 2020 avec l'arrêt de deux
réacteurs de Fessenheim c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui a osé écrire seulement il y a
2 ans la mise à l'arrêt de la centrale
de Fessenheim incarne l'écologie de
responsabilité que nous portons c'est
vous madame la Première ministre qui
n'écoutait pas mon propos elle est belle
votre fameuse écologie de responsabilité
qui conduit à la réouverture des
centrales à charbon bravo sans oublier
le sabordage d'Alstom energy qui
s'apparente à de la haute trahison le
raquette de DF organisé par l'État au
profit de groupe privé bénéficiant d'un
prix de rachat de l'électricité
scandaleusement bas votre soumission à
l'Allemagne qui payant les pots cassés
de sa propre politique a voulu détruire
l'avantage de la France votre doc sentez
maladies à une union européenne qui
refuse d'admettre le fiasco du marché de
l'électricité de la spéculation
l'explosion de la taxe c'est SPE plus
650 % mes chers collègues en 20 ans car
comble de tout ce sont les Français par
leur facture qui ont payé la destruction
de notre modèle énergétique alors
aujourd'hui comment s'en sortir le
préalable à tout est de regagner notre
indépendance c'est-à-dire notre
souveraineté énergétique revenons tout
d'abord à un prix national de
l'électricité alignée sur le coût de
production de nos centrales et ne me
dites pas que ce n'est pas possible
l'Espagne et le Portugal ont osé le
faire nos entreprises asphyxiées comme
les Français retrouvant alors des prix
abordables sans avoir besoin de votre
usine à gaz budgétaire
l'indépendance passe aussi par la
reconstruction d'un service public
d'électricité autour d'EDF sa
nationalisation ne doit pas conduire à
son démantèlement comme vous voulez le
faire en douce comme la révélé notre
collègue sous pression de Bruxelles
sachez dire définitivement stop à la
Commission et mettons fin à ce marché
factice de l'électricité en rétablissant
le monopole de l'opérateur public seul
garantit des investissements à long
terme mais ça vous en êtes incapable
malheureusement pour s'en sortir nous
devons aussi investir massivement à la
fois dans la rénovation thermique des
logements ce que vous avez refusé de
faire avec le 49.3 et dans notre parc
nucléaire qui permet à la France d'avoir
une énergie 5 à 6 fois moins carbonée
que celle de l'Allemagne quand
allez-vous arrêter avec l'écologie
spectacle qui gaspille des milliards
d'euros qui seraient beaucoup plus
utiles ailleurs contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit
dans votre discours l'éolien est un
mirage car la production d'électricité
n'est pas proportionnelle à la puissance
installée la preuve en 2021 le nucléaire
représente 44% de la puissance installée
mais à fourni
69% mes chers collègues de l'électricité
française tandis que l'éolien et le
soleil 32 gigawatts représente 23% de la
puissance et on produit seulement 10% de
l'électricité plus vous installez
d'éoliennes mes chers collègues plus il
faut installer des centrales à gaz ou
utiliser des vieilles centrales au fioul
et au charbon pour prendre le relais
quand il n'y a pas de vent et de soleil
voilà l'aberration sans parler du
massacre environnemental de nos paysages
et de nos côtes sauf au Touquet bien sûr
le président de la République a voulu
préserver la vue
n'oubliez jamais que pour simplement
remplacer Fessenheim il faudrait ajouter
plus de 2000 éoliennes ou 8000
existantes alors en vérité en vous
écoutant j'ai compris que vous étiez
incapable de tirer les leçons de vos
échecs alors que le chancelier allemand
vous fait un bras d'honneur en mettant
200 milliards d'euros sur la table pour
sauver ses entreprises vous continuez à
attendre une évolution de l'Union
européenne qui ne viendra jamais les
français payent très cher votre naïveté
votre cynisme et il est temps de changer
de politique
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Laurence Maillard méniori pour le groupe
renaissance pour 5 minutes
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues alors
depuis deux siècles l'énergie a
contribué à l'essor des transports de la
métallurgie de l'agroalimentaire du
numérique et de la science et bien sûr
façonner nos modes de vie alors depuis
deux siècles NRJ est source de puissance
d'innovation et de progrès mais il est
aussi à l'origine de grands désordre
géopolitiques et écologique et je veux
parler évidemment ici plus
particulièrement des énergies fossiles
qui ont tellement contribué à l'essor du
monde moderne mais qui menacent
aujourd'hui notre planète illuminité
tout entière alors telle les deux amants
terribles de Jean-Marc joncourci l'homme
et l'énergie se sont mutuellement
nourris enrichis mais en oubliant
l'essentiel la planète qui nous nourrit
la nature et la biodiversité l'air que
nous respirons la vie sur Terre et tous
ces Esco système fragiles sont
aujourd'hui menacés par le réchauffement
climatique alors l'homme et l'énergie
sont-ils aujourd'hui condamnés à se
détruire depuis les premières alertes
des scientifiques du GIEC qui après 30
ans de Coop des engagements ont été pris
par les étapes pour enrayer ce phénomène
trop tard diront certains pas assez
videront d'autres mais je crois que la
prise de conscience est là c'est
pourquoi la politique énergétique que
nous déterminerons pour les 15 20
prochaines années et cruciales et
stratégiques pour notre pays le défi est
immense et la feuille de route tracée
par notre majorité est claire la
sobriété sortir des énergies fossiles
pour baisser significativement les gaz à
effet de serre et gagner en indépendance
alors tout d'abord la sobriété alors
nous avons adopté en 2020 la stratégie
nationale bas carbone et elle prévoit la
réduction de notre consommation
d'énergie finale de 40% d'ici à 2050
c'est l'un des objectifs les plus
ambitieux d'Europe en la matière alors
la sobriété passe par d'importantes
économies d'énergie avec moins de
gaspillage bien sûr mais aussi par des
investissements massifs dans la
rénovation énergétique des secteurs les
plus émetteurs comme les logements et
les transports alors depuis 2020 ma
prime rénov a permis la rénovation d'un
million de logements en particulier ceux
des foyers les plus modestes et ce n'est
que le début la sobriété passe aussi par
l'innovation et par des investissements
importants dans les mobilités douces je
pense au plan vélo madame la Première
ministre que vous avez initié et dans
les transports des carbonés à cet agar
nous savons que beaucoup de nos
compatriotes continueront de dépendre de
la voiture et nous les aidons à changer
de véhicule avec d'importantes primes à
la Recon à la reconversion nous les
aidons d'autant plus que ces véhicules
électriques sont en appelés à être
remplacés les pardons les véhicules
électriques sont appelés à remplacer les
véhicules thermiques dans la fin et
programmée pour 2040 et ça nous la vol
dans la loi dans le monde a précédent
la sobriété n'est pas synonyme de
renoncement c'est un investissement
d'avenir et c'est un changement dans nos
habitudes nous nous réjouissons que le
plan de sobriété présenté il y a
quelques semaines par le gouvernement
s'inscrivent dans cette démarche en
visant la baisse de 10% de notre
consommation d'énergie d'ici 2024
ensuite il nous faut sortir des énergies
fossiles et là aussi la France et
l'Europe ont pris des engagements
ambitieux dans moins de 30 ans l'Union
européenne devrait atteindre la
neutralité carbone la France n'y
parviendra pas ni parviendra que si elle
verdit sa politique énergétique la
France doit presser le pas et comme il
nous reste un long chemin à parcourir le
président de la République a fixé un cap
clair dans son discours de Belfort en
février 2022 pour je cite reprendre en
main notre destin énergétique et pour y
parvenir un projet de loi avec des
battues dans les prochains jours à
l'Assemblée nationale il doit permettre
d'accélérer le développement de tout de
toutes les énergies renouvelables
solaires éolien géothermie hydraulique
et biomasse ce texte va nous permettre
de simplifier les procédures améliorer
l'acceptabilité de ses projets par nos
concitoyens mieux impliquer les élus
locaux mieux planifier et permettre un
meilleur partage de la valeur
ce texte vous l'avez déjà dit et le
premier pilier de la stratégie
énergétique de la France qui va se
conduire élaborer la PPE 2023 2024 le
second pilier étant le projet de loi
visant à l'accélérer la construction du
petit nucléaire et le projet de loi de
programmation énergique climat qui
arrive courant 2023 enfin la politique
énergétique doit être un levier pour
gagner en indépendance notre
consommation énergétique d'énergie
finale dépend toujours à 65% d'énergie
fossiles c'est qu'il nous rend
vulnérable dépendant de puissance
étrangères et cette situation nous
devons en sortir nous devons nous passer
d'énergie fossile pour garantir en
France un accès à une énergie souveraine
compétitive et décarbonée
mes chers collègues l'Assemblée
nationale est appelé à prendre des
décisions importantes pour la politique
énergétique de notre pays la majorité
présidentielle est prête et je ne doute
pas que toutes les bonnes volontés au
sein de notre assemblée sauront se
joindre à nous pour relever le défi du
siècle je vous remercie
je vous remercie chère collègues la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Mathias
Tavel pour le groupe de la France
insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres collègues la crise énergétique
est partout et vous demandez aux
Français de payer l'addition du marché
européen
un Français sur deux a déjà dû renoncer
à se chauffer alors qu'il avait froid
mais vous prévoyez un matraquage
tarifaire supplémentaire de 15% de
hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité au premier janvier des
entreprises sont à l'arrêt des milliers
d'emplois sont menacés par l'explosion
des prix comme chez Duralex mais vous
abandonnez les entreprises au prix du
marché des universités ferment une
partie de leur locaux les factures du
gaz sont multipliées par 5 par exemple
pour le collège de Trignac dans ma
circonscription et le système de
production électrique ne garantit même
plus l'absence de coupure cet hiver
voilà le terrible bilan de 5 ans de
politique énergétique macroniste vous
très réduit à devoir demander aux
citoyens de baisser le chauffage et de
mettre des cols roulés
non nous refusons cette logique et nous
disons clairement haut et fort les
factures c'est Macron les coupures c'est
Macron le chaos énergétique c'est Macron
nous débattons de la politique
énergétique du pays enfin dans cette
assemblée mais ne soyons pas dupe ce
débat est largement hypocrite vous
auriez pu décider d'engager le débat sur
la stratégie énergétique avec le pays
tout entier de convoquer y compris un
référendum pour faire arbitrer les
Français sur différents scénarios dont
un scénario à 100% d'énergie
renouvelable comme nous le défendons
mais vous faites le choix des conseils
de défense et d'un débat sans vote
aujourd'hui vous auriez pu engager la
sortie du marché de l'énergie mais vous
préférez protéger les super profits et
les conflits d'intérêts avec les groupes
privés jusqu'au sein de votre
gouvernement
vous pourriez tendre la main à la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale sur un sujet comme les énergies
renouvelables dont nous sommes les plus
grands partisans dans cette assemblée
mais le président de la République vous
intime sur ce sujet comme sur les autres
de regarder vers la droite monsieur
Macron a été condamné à deux reprises
pour son inaction climatique la France
macroniste est le seul pays de l'Union
Européenne le seul pays de l'Union
européenne à n'avoir pas atteint ses
objectifs de développement des
renouvelables en 2020 et 2021 ne venez
pas ensuite nous dire qu'on ne peut pas
désobéir aux règles européennes alors
que vous le faites vous-même mais vous
le faites mal vous le faites sur les
mauvais sujets et avec vous ce n'est
jamais pour engager l'indispensable quoi
qu'il en coûte écologique
pourtant il y a urgence
urgence pour le climat d'abord la France
se réchauffe 50% plus vite que les
précédentes estimations le laissaient
craindre il y a donc urgence à sortir
des énergies carbonées les scientifiques
le disent depuis des décennies avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon nous le proposons
depuis 2012 au pays et vous vous
procrastinez votre inaction est donc
coupable votre politique aggrave le
chaos climatique et sacrifie les
générations futures les experts du GIEC
nous alertent je cite pour le climat
tout va se jouer dans les 10 ans 10 ans
mais vous préférez censurer le Parlement
avec un 49-3 climaticide quand
l'Assemblée vote 15 milliards d'euros en
faveur de la rénovation des logements et
du transport ferroviaire
10 ans mais vous préférez les chimères
nucléaires pour 2035 ou 2040
c'est-à-dire hors délais pour l'urgence
climatique plutôt que l'action urgente
est juste pour la sobriété et les
renouvelables la sortie des énergies
carbonées dix ans mais vous laissez
continuer le marché à faire la loi au
lieu d'une vraie planification
écologique
il y a aussi urgence pour l'avenir du
pays a plus courte échéance encore cet
hiver illustre s'illus par
l'indisponibilité d'une grande partie du
parc nucléaire c'est que les incidents
corrosion fissures s'enchaînent et les
perspectives de remise en service ne
cessent de se décaler faute d'avoir
diversifié sa production énergétique
pour s'éloigner du tout nucléaire la
France se retrouve contrainte à un plan
pour éviter les coupures d'électricité
l'indépendance énergétique du pays n'est
pas assurer elle ne l'est pas par le
nucléaire qui dépend de l’uranium elle
ne l'est pas du fait de la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles le déficit
énergétique de la France s'élève à 83
milliards d'euros cette année
l'agressive guerre du gaz de Monsieur
Poutine vous rappelle à l'ordre mes
pensez-vous sérieusement que le gaz de
schiste américain ou le gaz
qatari tâché du sang des travailleurs
forcés change quoi que ce soit à la
situation notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles gaz et pétrole en tête et
contraire à l'intérêt général humain
face aux défis climatiques et à
l'indépendance nationale mais où est
votre plan pour sortir du carbone où
sont les plans des conversion des
filières industrielles vous n’êtes même
pas capable de soutenir clairement un
projet de conversion de la centrale au
charbon de Cordemais vous n’êtes même
pas capable de valoriser pleinement les
gisements d'énergie dont dispose
pourtant le pays et la mère est l'un
d'entre eux c'est une fierté pour la
circonscription de Saint-Nazaire que je
représente d'accueillir le premier parc
éolien en mer en service en France mais
le Danemark ouvrait le sien en 1991
que de temps perdu dans ces mandats
précédents pas seulement celui de
Monsieur Macron même s'il y a contribué
en se réveillant bien tard sur le sujet
que d'incertitude encore sur la
planification des projets à venir de
fait vos objectifs d'éolien en mer
s'avère six fois moins ambitieux que
ceux de l'Allemagne pour 2030 avec
pourtant une surface maritime largement
supérieure et je ne peux que regretter
l'absence du secrétaire d'État à la mer
dans ce débat sur ce sujet comme sur les
autres vous gouvernez contre l'intérêt
national
rappelons-nous en 2014 que Monsieur
Macron vendait la branche énergie
d'Alstom à général électrique
rappelons-nous en 2016 c'est l'éolien
emmerde Areva qui était cédé à gamessa
deux ans plus tard l'État actionnaire
majoritaire de naval group fermait
l'usine d'hydrolienne puis laisser
l'entreprise Photowatt délocaliser
l'assemblage de ces panneaux
photovoltaïques
et depuis juin qu'avez-vous fait vous
avez autorisé la réouverture d'une
centrale au charbon lancer la
construction d'un terminal métallier
flottant est nommé à la tête d'EDF que
vous allez démanteler un serial
privatiseur
en réalité votre politique n'est guidée
que par une seule chose le marché mais
on se rit des hommes qui déplorent les
effets dont il chérissent les causes car
les causes des hausses d'électricité des
pénuries sont claires elles sont
directement liées à la marchandisation
de l'électricité et à la case du service
public au nom des dogmes libéraux de
l'Union européenne
dans l'Europe libérale le prix du marché
est décorrélé des coûts de production et
même plusieurs fois celui-ci supérieur à
celui-ci au plus grand profit des
actionnaires on subventionne le
développement de distributeurs
d'électricité dont l'unique activité est
de revendre une énergie qu'il ne
produisent pas en spéculant sur les prix
dans l'Europe allemande le prix de
l'électricité se retrouve indexé sur
celui du gaz un fonctionnement que même
votre Ministre de l'économie juge
délirant en vain
l'échec du marché a organisé la
production est plus encore la
bifurcation énergétique et pas tant
alors si vous ne voulez pas écouter les
insoumis écouter au moins le président
du Medef je le cite pour l'énergie nous
sommes en guerre et le marché ne
fonctionne pas en économie de guerre
cela devrait obliger la Commission
européenne à acter cette réalité et donc
à suspendre les mécanismes de marché dit
Monsieur Roux de Bézieux il y a une
forme de dogmatisme au sein de certains
pays que je regrette
parlaient-ils de vous
c'est la fin d'une époque dont vous êtes
la queue de comète incapable de sortir
des impasses libérales que vous avez
vous-même contribué à créer collègue
pourtant un autre monde est possible
pour protéger les familles il est
commune les industries les PME pour
l'intérêt général nous avons besoin
d'une rupture républicaine l'énergie
n'est pas une marchandise c'est un bien
commun pillage et gaspillage du marché
ont assez duré face à la crise l'heure
est à la maîtrise publique et à la
planification écologique dont nous
parlons avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis
tant d'années un système français public
est nécessaire pour lequel la sortie du
marché européen est impérative et assez
de mauvaise foi sur ce sujet pour
échanger de l'électricité avec nos
voisins nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
marché européen nous avons besoin de
ligne à haute tension et elles existent
et elles continueront d'exister après le
marché européen
l'illusion selon laquelle la concurrence
ferait baisser les prix a vécu je crois
que nous sommes tous d'accord pour le
dire alors il y a urgence à rétablir un
tarif réglementé pour tous particuliers
collectivités entreprises il doit être
garanti y compris au-delà du premier
juillet 2023 pour le gaz il doit revenir
un tarif basé sur les cours réels de
production il doit inclure une part
gratuite pour les usages indispensables
à une vie digne et une surtaxation des
gaspillages dans l'immédiat il y a
urgence à bloquer les prix enfin une
diversification massive et urgente dans
les renouvelables et primordial assez du
fiasco du tout nucléaire de la mise en
route en mode dégradé de l'EPR comme on
le lit dans la presse à propos de
Flamanville et des brutalités à Bures
même les scénarios de RTE qui conservent
du nucléaire s'appuie tous sur une
augmentation forte de la part d'y
renouvelables si opposé comme le fait
Madame Le Pen c'est jouer contre la
France
mieux le scénario M0 de RTE l'ADEM
negawatts nous enseigne que 100%
renouvelables c'est possible il faut
seulement en avoir la volonté
manifestement vous ne l'avez pas nous
nous l'avons
la parole est un monsieur Guillaume
casse Barillon président de la
commission des affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre Madame et Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues l'énergie
est aujourd'hui au centre de toutes les
préoccupations la guerre menée par la
Russie contre l'Ukraine nous rappelle
qu'il est primordial de renforcer notre
souveraineté énergétique et de réduire
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
c'est la participe aussi de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique que
nous devons mener à l'heure où les
conséquences irréversibles de celui-ci
se manifeste aux yeux de tous notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement en énergie
est mise à rude épreuve nous avons dû
diversifier nos apports pour nous
libérer de la dépendance au gaz russe
dans le même temps le parc nucléaire
français subit une indisponibilité
importante avec encore 25 réacteurs à
l'arrêt sur les 56 que compte le pays
outre les maintenances à effectuer ces
arrêts sont dus vous le savez à
l'apparition de phénomènes de corrosion
sous contrainte ces tensions sur le
marché de l'énergie conduisent à des
envolés des montants des factures
d'électricité et de gaz tant pour nos
concitoyens pour nos entreprises et nos
collectivités face à la flambée des prix
le gouvernement a pris de nombreuses
mesures conjoncturelles de soutien pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
et garantir notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement pour réduire notre
dépendance au gaz russe la loi pouvoir
d'achat voté cet été nous donne la
faculté d'augmenter nos importations de
gaz naturel liquéfié grâce à la mise en
service d'un terminal métallier flottant
dans le port du Havre elle permet aussi
d'optimiser nos niveaux de stockage du
gaz ensuite le bouclier tarifaire mis en
place dès la loi de finances pour 2022 a
permis d'amortir le choc de l'inflation
pour les ménages et les plus petites
entreprises ils perdurera en 2023 en
limitant la hausse des factures à 15%
tant en gaz qu'en électricité le chèque
énergie aide aussi les foyers qui en ont
le plus besoin à faire face à leurs
dépenses
s'agissant des entreprises outre les
aides spécifiques destinées aux
entreprises électro-intensives un
amortisseur électricité a récemment été
mis en place afin de soutenir nos TPE et
PME non éligibles aux bouclier tarifaire
enfin professionnelle et particuliers
fournissent un effort collectif de
maîtrise de leur consommation d'énergie
au travers du plan de sobriété ces
mesures conjoncturelles ne nous
dispensent pas d'engager dès à présent
des actions structurantes pour mener à
bien notre politique énergétique à long
terme la France est donnée pour objectif
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 en parallèle RTE nous rappelle que
nos besoins en électricité vont
augmenter et qu'il est donc nécessaire
de développer nos moyens de production
d'électricité des carbonée pour cela
notre stratégie est claire il faut
décarboner notre mix énergétique en
s'appuyant sur la relance du nucléaire
et sur le développement des énergies
renouvelables un mix sans l'un et
l'autre ne peut pas fonctionner on ne
construit pas une centrale en un
claquement de doigts et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent donc nous aider
dès à présent à électrifier et
décarboner notre production le nucléaire
quant à lui nous amènera la puissance et
la pilotabilité de la production dont
nous avons besoin pour y parvenir
l'excellence de nos filières
industrielles est un atout et elle
bénéficieront de notre engagement résolu
dans la valorisation de ces deux types
d'énergie la participe d'ailleurs
pleinement au renforcement de notre
autonomie stratégique par ailleurs le
Parlement est saisi en ce moment de deux
lois sur les énergies renouvelables et
sur l'énergie nucléaire premièrement
nous examinerons dès la semaine
prochaine en commission des affaires
économiques et en commission du
développement durable le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable qui
doit permettre de simplifier et
d'accélérer d'accélérer les procédures
pour concrétiser les nombreux projets
qui émergent sur les territoires
deuxièmement début d'année prochaine
nous examinerons un projet de loi
relatif au nucléaires permettant cette
fois-ci d'accélérer la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs
après ces deux lois d'accélération et de
simplification viendra le temps de la
planification avec le vote d'une loi de
programmation quinquennale en 2023 sur
les priorités de notre politique
énergétique cette loi quinquennale mes
chers collègues c'est l'Assemblée
nationale qui l'a souhaité et qu'il a
créé au cours de l'examen de la loi
énergique climat en 2019 elle nous
permettra de débattre de notre futur
énergétique et des objectifs que nous
voulons fixer au niveau national ces
objectifs irriguant ensuite la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et les déclinaisons locales de notre
stratégie énergétique le Parlement au
travers de ces trois lois sera donc au
centre de l'élaboration de la politique
énergétique française et je suis
convaincu que nous avons toutes les clés
en main pour réussir le pari de la
décarbonation je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panier
runache ministre de la transition
énergétique
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame messieurs
les ministres madame première ministre
je crois que le Président de la
République a une ligne claire sur sa
politique énergétique cette ligne claire
on la connaît il s'agit de sortir des
énergies fossiles et elle tient en
quatre mots sobriété efficacité énergies
renouvelable nucléaire cette stratégie
elle va être soumise à la représentation
nationale pas de manière bâclée de
manière construite dans le cadre d'un
grand débat public qui a été lancé en
octobre ce débat public il a été monté
avec la Commission nationale du débat
public la question a été posée sur ses
rangs ce débat public il est aujourd'hui
accessible en ligne il donne lieu à des
rencontres physiques dans toutes les
régions avec les Français avec les élus
avec les partis prenantes de manière à
faire en sorte qu'on ait une réelle
concertation et qu'on associe tous les
Français à ce que vous avez décrit comme
étant un élément essentiel l'énergie un
élément stratégique un élément présent
dans l'existence de tous les Français et
je veux dire aussi que nous associerons
particulièrement les jeunes puisque nous
aurons une convention des jeunes en
janvier 200 jeunes de 18 à 35 ans
Monsieur Fournier précisément pour que
ceux-ci puisse se prononcer sur un débat
qui les concerne particulièrement dans
le contexte de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et donc je vous
invite chacun soit au titre des réunions
en région soit à contribuer sur la
plateforme pour apporter votre votre
part à ce grand débat public et à
l'animé avec dans vos circonscriptions
entendu si nous nous si nous vous avions
soumis un texte bâclé à la va-vite et
sans concertation donc nous prenons ce
temps pour préparer la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie nous prenons ce
temps pour préparer la stratégie
nationale bacarbonne et nous prenons ce
temps pour préparer la plantationale
d'adaptation au changement climatique
mais nous ne perdons pas de temps pour
agir pas de temps pour agir c'est
d'abord le plan sobriété c'est la
première fois que ce pays sous l'égide
de la première ministre dispose d'un
plan sobriété avec des objectifs clairs
et qui emportent pas seulement les
ménages qui ne soient pas une série
d'éco-gestes mais qui au contraire vise
à faire que les grands employeurs les
grandes entreprises les grandes
administrations les grandes
collectivités locales s'engagent à
réduire leur consommation d'énergie de
10% du carburant du gaz de l'électricité
et c'est ça qui change tout et je veux
dire ici que trois quarts des
entreprises déclarent avoir désormais un
plan sobriété je pense que ce résultat
mérite d'être souligné sur l'efficacité
énergétique ensuite c'est cette majorité
qui a massifié la rénovation thermique
merci à cette majorité qui était
présente sur ses bancs lors du précédent
quinquennat et qui a permis à 700 000
ménages par an de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre des mesures de rénovation
thermique alors vous pointerez du doigt
et vous aurez raison qu'on doit aller
plus loin qu'on doit aller plus fort
qu'on doit privilégier la rénovation
globale mais vous avez raison et nous le
partageons mais ce n'est pas en mon
votant un amendement on met beaucoup de
milliards qu'on le fait on s'en est déjà
parlé c'est en ayant les compétences
c'est en ayant les filières c'est en
faisant en sorte d'accompagner les
ménages dans le processus compliqué de
monter un dossier d'aller chercher les
meilleurs artisans pour les accompagner
et de faire en sorte que ces travaux
global le trouble pas trop leur maison
sur l'efficacité c'est aussi tout ce que
nous avons mis en oeuvre pour développer
les petites lignes de train pour faire
en sorte que nous privilégions le
transport les transferts intermodals et
diminuent l'empreinte carbone de notre
transport il ne s'agit pas seulement que
de verdir chaque type de transport il
s'agit bien de transformer nos modes de
transport avec des crédits à la clé je
rappelle que le plan de relance mis sur
la table près de 35 milliards d'euros 35
milliards d'euros pour décarboner notre
économie sur tous les secteurs du jeu en
matière d'efficacité énergétique je ne
reviendrai pas non plus sur l'action qui
a été menée en matière d'efficacité
énergétique dans l'industrie puisque
c'est près de 5 millions de tonnes CO2
par an qui ont été économisés et qui
permettent par le plan de relance avec
désormais une ligne très claire 5
milliards d'euros dans le plan France
investissement pour les 18 mois qui
viennent et 5 mill additionnels annoncés
par le Président de la République et mon
collègue Roland Lescure portera ce plan
avec l'ensemble des filières voilà des
résultats concrets pieds à pied secteur
par secteur et avec une ligne claire le
troisième enjeu il est celui de produire
plus d'énergie bas carbone pour sortir
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles vous avez été nombreux à le
pointer alors je veux monsieur
Dupont-Aignan rappelait que nous n'avons
jamais été souverain en matière
énergétique c'est un mythe nous sommes
dépendants des énergies fossiles depuis
des années des dizaines d'années la
réalité
mais depuis les années 70 depuis tous
les noms que nous avons articulé parce
que c'est une réalité physique le gaz et
le pétrole ne sont pas produits en
France ou ont été peu produits en France
vous êtes beaucoup sur ces bancs à
promouvoir à mix énergétique équilibré
pour sortir des énergies fossiles et je
crois que tout partageons totalement
cette approche c'est un enjeu
d'indépendance du pays un enjeu de
pouvoir d'achat un enjeu de
compétitivité des entreprises monsieur
Tanguy je suis un peu surprise de votre
propos très déterminé sur le tout
nucléaire car il n'a pas toujours été
aussi clair sur vos bancs et je veux
citer ici et je me concentre de citer
mes auteurs Marine Le Pen en 2011 qui
affirmait la sortie du nucléaire serait
positive elle limiterait les dangers
pour le monde elle doit passer par
l'investissement massif dans la
recherche concernant les nouvelles
énergies dois-je entendre que vous êtes
prêt à considérer le développement
accéléré des énergies renouvelables ce
serait une bonne nouvelle en 2017 je dis
le nucléaire est dangereux c'est un fait
et Monsieur Tanguy cité de manière
grandiloquente les grands hommes que a
connu notre pays monsieur Messmer
monsieur De Gaulle monsieur Chirac quand
on sait quel rôle ils ont joué par
rapport à la montée de l'extrême droite
c'est choquant et si je puis ici je
filme permettre monsieur Messmer
monsieur De Gaulle et Monsieur Chirac
doivent se retourner dans votre tombe
quand il vous écoute monsieur Tanguy
vous associez à leur mémoire
lutter contre la montée des extrêmes
droites c'est très clair
le deuxième le deuxième levier pour le
premier levier pardon pour accélérer la
sortie des énergies bas carbone c'est
donc le grand plan énergie renouvelable
que nous avons lancé et Monsieur Marleix
je veux vous rassurer l'enjeu est
d'abord de rattraper notre retard par
rapport à la programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie
antérieure et donc il est légitime
d'avoir un projet de loi maintenant qui
permette de rattraper ce qui n'a pas
encore été fait et nous adressons toutes
les énergies renouvelables la géothermie
nous allons lancer un plan dans les
prochaines semaines ce n'est pas un plan
de niveau législatif et je peux vous
dire que nous avons travaillé avec la
filière car à ce stade elles n'ont pas
besoin de mesures législatives le bio de
méthane nous avons libéré un terawatt
heure de biométhane par les mesures
réglementaires que nous avons pris le
photovoltaïque c'est la position de
multiplier par 10 notre production les
éoliennes marines c'est une filière
industrielle solide qui emploie
directement près de 6500 emplois et sur
lequel notre est exportateur aux
États-Unis au Royaume-Uni et dans
d'autres régions du monde et je crois
que nous devons être fiers de cette
filière industrielle alors oui vous avez
raison il faut une planification c'est
ce que propose le texte de projet de loi
sur les énergies renouvelables qui sort
du Sénat et qui a été voté à 300 voix
contre 5 contre 320 pour contre cinq
contre ce qui montre qu'aujourd'hui en
réalité nous sommes
dans un consensus sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables sur la nécessité
d'une planification qui fasse toute sa
place aux élus locaux et qui permettent
d'accélérer la production d'énergie
renouvelables et je ne vous invite
chacun à participer à contribuer à
enrichir ce texte
sur le nucléaire ensuite peut-être un
petit retour en arrière par rapport à ce
que j'ai entendu sur la disponibilité du
parc vous savez que la période dans
lequel la maintenance a été la plus
faible sur le parc nucléaire c'était
entre 2002 et 2008 entre 2002 et 2008
cette chute de la maintenance explique
une chute de la disponibilité de notre
productible nucléaire en 2009 et je vous
invite à revenir sur les chiffres 2009
Dominique Pottier disait avec raison
c'est 20 dernières années il y a eu un
peu de retard dans la prise de décision
il y a eu des hésitations et au fond ce
qu'on est en train de dire c'est que oui
on a certainement les uns et les autres
on aurait pu mieux faire mais au fond
cette responsabilité maintenant nous la
portons collectivement c'est à nous qui
appartient de dessiner le contour de
notre politique énergétique et nous
avons la capacité de la faire
collectivement nous avons la capacité de
la faire en votant un projet de loi sur
les énergies renouvelables qui soit
ambitieux nous avons la capacité de la
faire en travaillant sur la relance de
la filière nucléaire avec un groupe EDF
qui soit le bras armé de notre politique
énergétique et donc pour répondre aussi
à cette question il n'est pas évident
question de démanteler EDF c'est au
contraire un élément central dans notre
stratégie sur les enjeux du nucléaire
sur les enjeux de l'hydraulique sur les
enjeux des réseaux et notre ligne c'est
d'atteindre l'excellence opérationnelle
et industriel sur tous ces enjeux notre
ambition c'est également de lancer la
production de six nouveaux opère vous
aurez le loisir de décider ces six
nouveaux EPR et éventuellement les 8
autres qui pourraient leur succéder
puisque nous présenterons à la
représentation nationale ce mix
énergétique et afin de ne pas prendre de
retard nous avons préparé un projet de
loi sur le nucléaire qui permettent
d'anticiper les
procédure administrative pour la
construction de nouveaux sites donc nous
ne préentetons pas la décision sur la
construction de nouveaux EPR nous sommes
clairs dans nos recommandations mais
d'ores et déjà parce que nous anticipons
nous vous proposerons au début de
l'année un projet de loi pour accélérer
les procédures administratives de
construction de pairs et faire en sorte
que ces procédures ne retardent pas les
choix que vous ferez dans la loi énergie
climat je voudrais revenir maintenant
sur quelques points la protection des
Français oui nous faisons face à une
crise énergétique sans pareil depuis des
années mais nous avons aussi pris des
décisions sans pareil pour protéger les
Français le bouclier énergétique permet
aujourd'hui aux Français d'avoir le prix
d'électricité le plus faible d'Europe
c'est une réalité
c'est une réalité le bouclier
énergétique permet au TPE et aux petites
collectivités locales d'avoir le prix
l'électricité le plus bas d'Europe c'est
une réalité et nous avons pris nos
responsabilités y compris en allant
prendre la rente inframarginale des
producteurs d'électricité qui
bénéficiaient de l'effet d'aubaine de la
montée des prix de l'énergie et donc
nous avons pris nos responsabilités pour
redistribuer cette rentrante au plus
précaire au plus vulnérable vous
mentionnez l'augmentation du prix de 15%
et vous avez raison monsieur marlex
monsieur le des monsieur le Président
Marleix pour les Français les plus
vulnérables et c'est pour cette raison
que nous avons accompagné cette
augmentation qui est sensible pour les
Français les plus vulnérables d'une
augmentation du chèque énergie de façon
à ce qu'elle soit beaucoup moins forte
pour ces Français les plus vulnérables
et même les classes moyennes puisque le
chèque énergie qu'on
concernera pardon 40% de déménage
français 40% des ménages français
quelques mots sur la réforme du marché
de l'électricité au niveau européen cela
fait deux ans maintenant que Bruno Le
Maire que mon prédécesseur que mes
prédécesseurs
ont fait des propositions au niveau
européen précisément pour aller dans le
sens que vous souhaitez je crois que
nous nous retrouverons sur ça c'est à
dire avoir un prix de l'électricité qui
soit plus proche de la réalité de notre
mix énergétique la Commission européenne
a indiqué il y a deux semaines qu'elle
ferait des propositions pour revoir ce
design de marché d'ici la fin d'année et
nous allons
reprenons les propositions françaises et
nous allons donc continuer à y
travailler au niveau
international enfin Monsieur potier vous
questionné notre
partie du traité de Paris donc elle a
été signée aujourd'hui la lettre des
trois ministres a été signé aujourd'hui
il s'agissant de la position que nous
tiendrons ça sera une abstention pour
vous répondre très directement de même
je veux dire ici que la France est un
des pays les plus engagés je serai à la
Coop 25 tout à l'heure est un des pays
les plus engagés en matière
d'accompagnement des pays en
développement c'est 6 milliards d'euros
chaque année que la France consacre à
l'accompagnement des pays en
développement pour les aider notamment à
l'adaptation au changement climatique
pour permettre de développer des
énergies renouvelables et éviter de
développer des énergies fossiles et je
veux dire encore que c'est cette
majorité qui a mis un coup d'arrêt au
soutien à l'exportation aux énergies
fossiles donc nous avons une ligne
claire le président de la République a
montré le chemin le gouvernement est
engagé la première ministre porte la
planification écologique dont le volet
énergétique et tout cela nous permettra
ensemble de construire une trajectoire
de décarbonation de notre économie qui
soit à la fois juste pour les Français
et efficace pour
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique je vous remercie
la parole est un âme la première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je voulais mon
tour dire quelques mots en conclusion de
ce débat d'abord pour remercier les
oratrices et les orateurs qui ont pris
la parole aujourd'hui j'ai entendu des
débats constructifs
j'ai constaté des différences d'approche
et parfois de vision entre nous c'est
normal et c'est sain en démocratie
mais j'ai noté aussi chez beaucoup des
objectifs partagés et des convergences
sur notre stratégie pour la transition
énergétique
c'est sur elle je crois que nous pouvons
que nous devons nous appuyer dans les
années à venir
je crois que nous partageons tous une
volonté de sortir rapidement des
énergies fossiles de baisser nos
consommations grâce notamment à une
politique ambitieuse en termes de
mobilité propre et de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments une volonté de
diminuer les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et de reconquérir notre
souveraineté énergétique ce sont des
points structurants et ils montrent que
nous pouvons partager sur la plupart de
ces bancs une volonté et des objectifs
mesdames et messieurs les députés au
cours de nos échanges le principal
clivage est apparu sur la composition de
notre mix énergétique
j'assume totalement de suivre nos
experts et de plaider pour un mix
équilibré entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables
un mix diversifié c'est une protection
c'est une liberté
car je l'ai dit et je le répète ici il
n'y a pas de source d'énergie miracle
pur et parfaite chacune assez risque et
ses défauts
le nucléaire permet une production
d'énergie massive souveraine sans
émission et à coup maîtriser mais nous
ne pouvons pas faire croire non plus
qu'il s'agit d'une source d'énergie tout
à fait anodine ou que nous serions à
l'abri de défauts systémiques sur nos
réacteurs
de leur côté les énergies renouvelables
sont totalement décarbonées et
bénéfiques pour notre économie mais
n'oublions pas qu'elles sont aussi
intermittentes et qu'elle pose de
réelles questions d'acceptabilité alors
travaillons ensemble sur la
planification territoriale dans le
projet de loi sur l'accélération des
énergies des énergies renouvelables vous
êtes nombreux à le demander
une transition énergétique efficace
passera donc par la diversification en
avançant sur deux jambes le renouvelable
et le nucléaire
enfin et je le regrette il y a eu au
cours de ce débat quelque postures des
procès d'intention ou des écarts avec
l'histoire et la réalité des faits
dans un exercice de réécriture du passé
dont le rassemblement national et
coutumier l'extrême droite s'est inventé
une constance en matière nucléaire
je me rappelle pour ma part qu'il y a 10
ans la présidente de votre groupe
plaidait pour la sortie du nucléaire
nous étions peu après Fukushima son
opinion a sans doute changé avec les
sondages sur l'énergie ce sont
manifestement vos idées qui sont
renouvelables
nous avons
nous avons également eu l'occasion de
revenir sur l'état actuel de notre parc
nucléaire je le dis sans faux semblant
personne ne peut se satisfaire de la
situation actuelle mais je crois qu'il
n'est pas besoin de rentrer dans les
excès de convoquer les heures les plus
sombres de notre histoire pour appuyer
sa démonstration la situation actuelle
et le résultat de 20 ans de gestion de
notre parc nucléaire et ceux qui donnent
des leçons aujourd'hui ne sont pas
indemnes de responsabilité
allô alors j'appelle chacun à une
certaine humilité et à chercher des
solutions plutôt que des responsables le
projet de loi sur le nucléaire présenté
en Conseil des ministres au début de ce
mois peut-être peut-on être l'occasion
il va permettre de lever des contraintes
administratives et d'accélérer certains
projets alors travaillons ensemble sur
ce texte
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
débat a été riche et dense il ouvre un
cycle sur notre politique énergétique
avec dans quelques dans quelques jours
un texte pour accélérer la réalisation
des projets d'énergie renouvelables puis
dans le même esprit un projet de loi
pour accélérer les procédures
d'autorisation sur le nucléaire comme la
ministre de la transition énergétique la
rappeler il s'agit de deux textes
d'urgence sans attendre la présentation
d'une loi de programmation énergique
climat à l'issue des débats en cours
sous l'égide de la Commission nationale
du débat public et j'espère que beaucoup
de nos concitoyens pourront participer à
ces débats
ce débat public ces différents projets
de loi sont des étapes fortes
déterminant pour notre souveraineté pour
le climat et pour le pouvoir d'achat ce
sont des textes sur lequel nous pouvons
trouver j'en suis sûr des convergences
et des points d'accord les enjeux sont
grands travaillons ensemble pour les
Français je vous remercie
le débat est donc clos prochaine séance
ce soir à 21h30 avec la suite du projet
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la séance est
levée